what they can control in those actions considered immoral by
the opposing party. Yes. Okay. I'm not really sure to be honest
with you. Powerful stuff. Continue. Yeah. Like he literally just
takes what the IDF says and he's like this is just correct. Oh,
who's it verified by? Literally nobody. Okay. Uh does does Hamas
agree? Does Hamas Cuz listen, if both Hamas and the IDF agree
and it's like dude, every building is here. Everything is What
do you mean it's not as destroyed? I just zoomed in on a random
area. This is insane devastation. Just hearing people endlessly
go, "Oh yeah, Hassan just doesn't believe anything in this report."
That's not what he thinks. That's not what he says ever. Sure.
Anyone got a sick grandma? I'm pretty sure it's got free beds.
Okay. Jesus Christ. All right. Maybe that maybe that's just the
the parking lot or something. Maybe this is actually Alifa Hospital.
Here it is. Heading there.
I must say this is Oh, every time he calls himself Canadian,
we actually need to take this guy's passport immediately. Please,
please take his passport immediately. Okay. I feel like you guys
know enough that we could go over to the the Israel Palestine
conversation with the Cheeto. Okay. And just watch. You guys
want to watch this is this is going to be peak Hassan bad. Okay.
Okay. Correct me if I'm wrong. I think the obsession thing went
both ways, right? I think the We're talking about E. They're
talking about Ethan Klein here. Ethan Klein and Hassan and their
spiral obsession going on. I think we basically had about 50%.
50%. It was like 50/50. Ethan had an insane number of Instagram
stories. Hassan had a bunch of videos there. Why deny that there's
like a there's like a content spiral happening there that you're
both obsessed with each other and and yeah, you're both obsessed.
Okay, it's obvious the planet. But uh I would go Ethan got obsessed
before Hassan did. I mean, that's just whatever. I don't I don't
know if that's true, but either way, it's both.
Every single one of my videos, I think individually, is pretty
much damning enough to end the career of an average guy, right?
Is any one of them as bad as basically reacting to on stream
with your friends and then publishing that to YouTube or as bad
as using drawn pictures of a child being by a dog for a thumbnail
in a YouTube video? Are any of Hassan's allegations on that level
or does Knox just have no calibration for what cancels the average
person?
Like I know it seems like, oh, I can't believe he made 20 videos
on this guy, but I feel like each one individually is enough.
It's crazy. Yeah. So, uh yeah, when you're dealing with uh straight
up propaganda and lies and terror, Ethan's reactions gone way
overboard than anything Hassan has done. I don't know about that.
I don't know about that. I don't think so. I think like I think
it's pretty approximate on both sides. That's my read. I think
Ethan has gone after other people, but again, it's like other
than the No Samson lawsuit, it seemed like reasonably approximate
on every side of that, right? Has Ethan done more? But yeah.
Yeah, but Ethan's also been under attack by like 10 different
content creators, right? So, but I I'd say in terms of his responses
to each of them, it's not like so insanely escalatory that it's
like un unfathomable. It's like not shocking at all. Support
daily on the stream. A lot of it is um not super easy to to see.
What about the lawsuit? I said other than the lawsuit with Noah
Samson, which is a total like Yeah, it's a total move. Obviously,
looks really bad. Is in my opinion pretty much just to have the
financial chilling effect on Noah Samson that he didn't get that
it would basically just like pressure him to take his stuff down.
I think that's all it was was basically I'm threatening you with
a lawsuit. You'll take this down or you'll you'll risk losing
a bunch of money. And it didn't work. No. Samson kept his up.
So right away a lot of it is really easy like you know when he
goes 10 tones down I support Houthy terrorists and um Houthy
terrorists you know caused the deaths of 377,000 people in Yemen
like they're wait is he blaming the entire famine on the Houthies?
Is he just going to blame that entire Saudi caused famine on
the Houthies? Really? That's not what he's doing is it?
377,000 people Yemen the estimated the war in Yemen had killed
377,000 people by the end of 2021 through direct and indirect
causes. Over 150,000 of these deaths were a direct result of
the armed conflict. Well uh well far more than well far more
have died due to hunger and disease as a result of the humanitarian
crisis caused by the war. That's only on He's only placing that
apparently that total on one side. Cool. Yemen famine was real
bad. Yeah, I know. The Yemen famine was really bad. Yeah, I know.
I know it was horrible. I believe it is mostly attributed to
Saudi Arabia directly targeting like crops and stuff, isn't it?
Am I crazy? I could have sworn that it was mostly like the Saudis
were doing like insane insane tactics that they were being consistently
sanctioned
Uh, who caused famine in Yemen? Let's just see. Let's just throw
it up. Famine in Yemen 2016 to present. Since 2016, a food insecurity
crisis has been ongoing in Yemen, which began during the Yemen
civil war. The UN estimates that the war has caused an estimated
hold on I need to zoom in. That the war has caused an estimated
130,000 deaths from indirect causes which lack include lack of
food, health, services, and infrastructure as of December
2020. The main cause of the crisis is the ongoing Yemeni civil
war. Aid often cannot be effectively cannot effectively reach
often cannot effectively reach the population because of the
ongoing civil war and the blockade of Yemen by Saudi Arabia which
started in 2015. The blockade was intensified in November of
2017 when the closure of all sea land ports and then partially
but not fully uh sorry the closure of all seen land ports and
then partially but not fully lifted at the end of the month and
some humanitarian aid supplies were allowed to enter the country.
I thought this is basically like Saudi Arabia doing a lot of
like food control over over this population causing a lot of
people to starve to death. Crops, grocery stores. Yeah, this
was, by the way, this is my understanding from like way before
too, that the Saudis basically were like, "Okay, you I believe
the Saudis backed like the I believe it was a royal regime in
Yemen. They backed that group and then there were there were
different like there's like a civil war and the Houthis were
one of the groups that opposed them, right? And Saudi Arabia
as like penants because I think the Houthis and the other groups
basically ran the royal family out. This is my like this is my
vague recollection of the Yemeni civil war by the way. I'm like
talking through it a little bit. I think that's that's broadly
around around what happened. And then Saudi Arabia has been extremely
punitive going the other direction. So like ludicrously punitive
to the point that I think pretty much everybody just admits they're
totally out of their minds with how they treat the Yemenes. They're
not good people. Wow. I didn't know that. That many Wow. Well,
they didn't directly kill them, but they uh they caused a lot
of these deaths. They contributed to them because um
basically Yemen is one of the poorest countries in the world.
Um the Houthies kind of insurrect like took over the government
a little bit. Um they killed a lot of uh political leaders. They
steal lots of the humanitarian aid and the food that they use
for themselves and that they use to make rockets and missiles.
Wait.
Okay. This guy's just copy pasting Hamas Hasbro to attack the
Houthies. He literally just copy pasted it. Bro, they're making
rockets out of cookies. Okay. That's what they do. That's what
they do. There's no way. Um that caused a massive humanitarian
crisis in Yemen. They also directly killed lots of Yeah, they're
horrible. Yeah, they're they're horrible people, right? Um so
when he says he supports the terrorists because at least the
terrorist Dude, do we do we search Houthies
stealing humanitarian aid? Egregious record. Yemen's Houthies.
We'll we'll look this up, too. Okay. Yemen's Houthies denounced
for blocking aid. UN calls Yemen the world's worst humanitarian
crisis with 80% of the population of 30 million in need of aid.
The Houthi rebels as well as other parties in the conflict of
Yemen are to blame. Okay, hold on. As well as other parties.
Okay. The Houthies who control the capital of SA and much of
the north have a particularly egregious record of obstructing
aid agencies from reaching civilians in need according to HR.Human
Human Rights Watch, including by diverting relief items into
their to their own organization, blocking aid containers at the
ports they control, and even preventing aid assessments to identify
people's need. Okay, so it seems like the Houthis are putting
it are doing some of it. Okay, we just we just need to read.
The human rights organizations also reported that the obstruction
in government uh in government held areas of Yemen has also increased
and noted that the Saudiled coalition which backs the Yemeni
government has imposed a naval and air blockade on Yemen since
March of 2015 restricting the import of food, fuel and medicine.
The difficulties facing the work. So okay, it seems like it's
placing the blame on both of them and is not just international
aid organizations facing obstructions. Muna Lukeman, executive
director of food for humanity, described the Yemen NGO's experiences
with the Houthis. When our aid is delivered to the port in Haida
Haida, we find that a portion of it will have been stolen before
it leaves the port. Lukeman told Alzer, "There's also pressure
pressure to send aid to areas where the Houthis wanted to go.
We had a project in Hadida and they forced us to send it to SA.
We eventually found a compromise and split the aid, but the international
organizations often simply agree with them." For their part,
the Houthies respond to HR responded to HR criticisms, sorry,
by saying the group did not want to obstruct aid. And the allegations
were coming from aid agencies that followed political orders
from the United States. They're saying, "Hey, we didn't do that."
And again, I guess we'd have to see. We'd have to look more into
this and see like specific instances. And my understanding was
this had a lot to do overall with the Saudis, like more more
than the more than the Houthies. That's been my understanding
from like the start. But start bombing Israel. We'll just we'll
uh we'll keep looking into it as Nux makes claims.
Yeah, they're horrible. Yeah, they're they're horrible people,
right? Um so when he says he supports the terrorists because
at least the terrorists are bombing Israel and it's like a they're
also going to shut down the Twitch here, guys. We're going to
shut down the Twitch. Go kick only. Okay, we'll see you guys
in just a little bit over on kick. Okay, kick only. Okay, love
you guys. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye bye. Hold
on. On. Let me put this in here. Like that. Let me pin that.
Okay. Yes. Okay. Yes. Okay. We're good there. We're good there.
They're bombing civilians. B they're bombing American ships.
C they're kidnapping Filipino sailors randomly. And D they're
torturing their own people only. A they're bombing civilians.
B they're bombing civilians. So they're they are shooting rockets
at Israel. I do not believe they've landed a single rocket in
Israel or hurt a single person in Israel so far. Am I Am I right
or wrong on that? I do not believe we've seen anybody actually
hurt in Israel. I don't think so. Okay. So, bombing civilians,
they've not they've not bombed civilians. They have targeted
civilians probably. Okay. They're bombing American ships. See,
they're kidnapping. Nothing of that has been proven or any evidence.
That is entirely wrong. Critical RAD, I don't know who told you
that the Houthies objectively shoot many, many, many missiles
at Israel. I don't know who told you. There's no evidence they
shoot. They absolutely shoot missiles at Israel. I don't I don't
know what that is. Uh what was B? Civilians. B they're bombing
American ships. B they're bombing American ships. They have tried
to attack American ships. They have tried to attack American
naval vessels uh to absolutely no effect because AK-47s don't
do anything to destroyers. Okay, you roll up on an American destroyer
in a fishing boat with AK-47s. Okay, you're gonna get it's not
gonna work. You fire your AK-47 at an American Apache helicopter.
That's not going to work out for you. That's what they tried
to do. Now, bombing American ships. I mean, they are trying to
bomb any shipping going through the the Red Sea. Yes. Okay. They
got a soft on an F-18. Is that I I know that F-18s have gone
down over the Red Sea. I didn't think it was over the uh the
Houthies hitting them, but maybe it was. Didn't they blow up
like one random tanker? I think they hit a tanker badly enough
that it had to stop or go somewhere, but I don't think they blew
it up. I don't think they like actually blew it up. They they
like caused substantial damage to one. I thought they destroyed
a Reaper drones. Oh, cool. That's why it's very expensive to
oppose the Houthies. Okay. Because they're on a shoestring budget.
It's like any gorilla operation really. They're on a shoestring
budget and bombing them cost a money. It's [__] up.
See, they're kidnapping Filipino sailors randomly. And D, they're
torturing their own people. Only 6% of the people in Yemen like
the Houthies. The other 94 Oh, the carrier had to evade. There's
an aircraft carrier that had to evade and it dumped an F-18 overboard.
I see. I see. It's a little different. That's kind of funny.
So, people are being oppressed.
So, is it kind of like the cartel? Okay. What was D? I So, it
was bombing civilians, bombing American vessels, uh, capturing
random Filipinos, that's the galaxy leader, and then torturing
their own people. I don't know about I I don't know how much
torturing their own people. They're they're a like a a religious
terrorist group. We'll just call them a terrorist group. Okay.
So, I don't I don't doubt that there are human rights abuses
happening there. Okay. That's his allegations.
Like in Mexico in terms of like how the public looks at it because
the public doesn't really have a choice. Like they can't vote
out the cartel. Um I I suppose it's similar to that. The major
difference is I suppose the cartel whose main purpose is making
crazy amounts of money from what I understand. Um the Houthies
are fighting like a extremist religious war. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. I understand. That makes sense. They they throw gay
people off buildings and [__] right? Okay. Um so
then when Hassan basically so the the kid that he had on his
stream that everyone has seen by now, the um Ye he's Yemen pirate,
right? That's what he is. Yep. Yep. Okay. Yep. So this kid who
he glazed and said was akin to Luffy, which is uh not a Yemen
pirate. Not not somebody who's like a fighter, somebody who's
like affiliated loosely with the Hookies. Insane. is basically
part of the group of people that is doing all of these things
actively. Like this isn't like oh you know this happened and
in the past like this group like he like if if you call someone
a Nazi now they're not part of the Nazi group that's doing gassings
right but with him he's part of the group that is actively doing
[__] Yeah. Uh not provably so. Uh he's advertised
himself as that. I do think if if there is a a hard link that
you could call him like the sort of like the marketing arm of
the Houthies now is that is that the argument that that this
guy's going to make though. Okay, that's my argument for why
you could consider him a part of the Houthies. But I don't think
anybody really makes that argument. Most of the time it's like
this guy was on the ship. This guy went and like kidnapped those
people off the ship. This guy's a militant. This guy is an AK-47.
And so I think um we'll see what the point Nux is, what it is
that he makes. But I I think I have like a subtler point where
it's like you're kind of doing marketing and we could consider
that a part of it. Yeah. Pumpern nickel. I that's my argument,
but most people don't make that argument. Most people argue that
he is a like he he's like a literal um militant. So do you disagree
with Queen's take on this? I don't know. So currently Hassan
I do know that if I disagree with him I we've discussed it enough
over the past week that we've definitely had the argument at
some point as like literally every time we talk we're arguing
about Hassan's stuff is denying that that as he calls him Yemen
teenager is actually part of the Houthies directly. However that
Yemen teenager did himself say that he is a soldier for the Houthies.
He said that himself. Um so again you could believe him or not.
So that's one thing he said. Uh, another thing that he has done
is he was hanging out with the prisoners that were kidnapped
by Houthies. Okay. Now, I believe he said this, but I don't exactly
know which interview he said it in. I remember him saying it.
Okay. I remember him saying it somewhere. Now, there is not a
video of him dancing with them. He described dancing with them.
He described partying with them, right? So, I don't know. I don't
know exactly where the truth is there. Okay, pause right there.
I want you to reiterate that point after I say what I think about
what you're what you just first said, right? I think when like
Hassan actually has something to lose, right? So he will deny
that what you know who the person that he platformed
um he'll deny that that person is as bad as people are saying,
right? Whereas the kid will not because he has nothing to lose
and he takes pride in it. I think there's the big difference.
The kid the kid posted uh like if you'd see what that Okay, we're
calling him a kid. He's a 19-year-old. He's not really a kid.
Hean calls him a kid, which could be accurate because the Houthies
use child slave soldiers. Yeah. Not very good people. Um but
um but this kid, it's like saying Austrian painter. Exactly.
So this kid um
was hanging out with with the the
um hostages that were captured by Houthies. Like so I don't know
how they're rather I say Filipino. I don't like that this guy
copies it. Now, I want to be more specific and say like, well,
they weren't all Filipino actually. Oh, he got to those people,
but um he probably had something to do with the Houthie movement.
Okay, gotcha. Okay, so then you were saying that it had he had
something to do with taking people prisoner. So, he took people
prisoner. So, the Houthies are a hipster pirate group that bombs
ships and kidnaps whoever they can basically. They say that they're
doing it to fight for Palestine. Uh they are not actually fighting
for anything because they are just bombing civilians. There was
a ship going I believe from Where are they? Wait, where are they?
They're just bombing civilians. They're trying to pressure Israel.
Like it's you could say they're just bombing civilians. They're
launching rockets at Israel. I don't know. Some of them are cruise
missiles. They probably have some amount of targeting. I don't
know if they're all going to just land in civilian areas. I will
say their last strike seem to land pretty close to some civilian
areas. I don't really mostly believe that they have the sophistication
to target, you know, military installations. I don't know if
they'd do that even if they could. They got one of two Israeli
ports shut down. Okay. Yeah. I think their their goal has been
to pressure Israel into uh basically we're going to keep shooting
rockets at you. Iran keeps giving us rockets to shoot at you.
We're going to do that for a while. India to turn Are they bombing
civilians in Israel? Uh yeah, they're they do basically daily.
So please ask please ask the question, have they harmed a civilian
in Israel? Hold on. Let's just I I realize it's super cheap to
just use Google for all of this, but have the Houthis killed
an Israeli civilian? IDF says it shot down Houthi Houthy missile
that triggered sirens across central Israel. Okay. Two civilians
killed in the Red Sea crisis in October 2023.
Israelis building injured. I don't know where the two Israelis
got killed. So, this is just talking about the overall Red Sea
crisis this entire thing. Okay. But I don't know where those
Israeli civilians got killed. Can I get 50? WFP says staff member
deni. Oh, there's no there's no two Israeli civilians killed.
Were they killed in Israel? Were they bombed in Israel? If somebody
could just tell me. I don't know. So, I'm not going to say they're
not trying to bomb citizens. I just When you say they bombed
citizens, I'm I'm trying to figure it out. Okay. That's just
what I'm trying to do. Well, they stopped because they got bombed
back. Uh but they they'll probably start up against it. Well,
I mean I mean just to play devil's advocate, wouldn't that make
sense then for them to say that they're doing it for Palestine
if it's against Israel? Um, well, the way I see it, if you are
doing something, then that thing that you do should probably
result in something. I'll I'll ask you a hypothetical. The Hamas
terrorists that started the entire Do we not believe that you
can like threaten one thing to demand another? Like I understand
it's like, okay, you you're trying to rob a bank, you took hostages,
right? It's like, well, that's really bad. But it's like, it's
not like the taking those hostages directly helps you, but those
hostages can be like exchange. I don't know. Houthis have the
ability to wage war. They're saying, "We'll stop waging war against
you if you do something else in Gaza." Right? Well, they don't
really have a lot of money. They can't offer you money, right?
They can offer you the absolute disregard with which they hold
their lives. That's what they can offer you. Okay? We will a
lot of us will die making sure you hurt. That's that's what they
have. That's what they can trade. Okay? That's what they got
in the in the bank. All right. That's what they're doing. War
that currently uh you know resulted in Right. Right. Which was
October 7th. Right. October 7th. Would you say that Hamas did
good for Palestine when they did that? I think they think they
did. I don't I wouldn't say they did. No, I don't think they
did. I think they wanted to Jews because that's what they said.
They said um No. I think a lot of people in Gaza were super psyched
about that when it happened that they'd made Israel bleed. I
think I just think they just didn't I don't know. They probably
foresaw at least like that Israel was going to come back on them
hard. I don't know if they foresaw this, but like they definitely
were psyched that they made Israel bleed. They were very happy
about that in the moment. Said themselves that they're doing
it to kill Jews. Is that true? Yep. They said that. That is literally
what the Hamas terrorists say. That's what the charter says.
That's what they said. Um, and they knew that it didn't help
Palestine or Gaza or anything like that because Israel hit back
and realistically it's horrible, right? So, so you think you
think I'd say at this point Gaza has turned on them. Gaza is
doing demonstrations against Hamas. They do not like their government
currently. But I I don't think when that first happened, I don't
think that was the case. Porter Beller, thank you for the 16
months. They actually cared that they wouldn't have done it in
the first place because they knew that they would have the consequences
to face. Well, first of all, yes. Second of all, bro, I don't
think you realize how bad it is in Gaza. The Palestinian civilians
in the Palestinian civilians in Gaza were protesting Hamas. They
said, because something you have to realize, Israel said from
the beginning, if Hamas surrenders and gives up the hostages,
the war is over. There are still currently hostages. Hostages
from October 7th. From October 7th. Still? Yeah. Oh, wow. There's
still like 50 left that they that they're holding. This is the
whole thing. This is very interesting. There's like a way to
catch people here that I haven't thought through. I need to like
spend some time actually writing some stuff down. But um there's
like this required belief amongst people who think the current
Gaza war and like how it progressed up until this point is like
morally justified. There's a certain belief they have to have
that's like the only thing that you should be concerned with
is the intent of the group. That basically as long as Hamas has
any genocidal intent for Jewish people that you can do anything.
It doesn't matter what happens, right? It's like we we don't
have to consider anything else because there are these people
who want to like all Jews, right? And we can do anything because
they've already tried. They've already hurt people and we can
do anything. And uh I don't know if Supreme was like that. It
doesn't really matter to me what what was being said there to
be honest. Um but you basically have like this intent and there's
like got to be a limit to it, right? And most people have limits
but they don't think about what the limits are and then they
soft they they they soften on the limits. If you just told somebody
like, "Hey, at 10,000 people, 10,000 deaths, Israel probably
needs to stop, right? This we'll talk like this and we'll avoid
loner box." I have no idea. Are you talking about me or one of
these two? I actually don't know who you're talking about. Um,
in any case, people I like that was when we first did Israel
Palestine debates on like in like November, sorry, December,
like when my stream first started. I always ask people what their
Hitler number was. What's your Hitler number? At what point is
it wrong? How many people have to die in Gaza before you're like,
"Okay, Israel's gone too far. What What's the number?" And 10,000
was like astronomical to people at that point. I was saying like
10,000. I think 10,000 is like crazy, right? It's crazy. And
people like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. 10,000 is insane. I don't
have a Hitler number. I have a Hitler percentage." Okay. Hated
that question. Lots of people hate that question. But it's like,
dude, there has to be a point where you're like, after we've
But there wasn't. And because nobody would pick that number.
Nobody would say like when it's too much then basically you just
you were signing a blank check for Israel and they did just roll
through that whole place and they destroyed the whole thing.
It's exactly I dude I wish I had the logs or the thoughts of
my old Israel Palestine debates. I was correct on everything
I said. I I wish I had I should go try to find the litterbox
one. I should go try to find because lurbox community used to
know me as the ethical um ethnic cleansing person. I was like,
uh, at this point I would try to get as evacuate as many citizens
from Gaza as I can, wherever I can, anywhere in the world because
I'm guessing they're going to get destroyed, right? Guessing
you haven't seen the latest Google Earth photos, huh? What is
Gaza not destroyed? Is Gaza like still standing mostly or something?
Am I totally mistaken? But yeah, I was like, dude, you have to
get them you have to get them out cuz I Israel is not going to
stop at all. I was correct. Please believe me without evidence.
Uh, no. Everybody who's back who was around back then knows exactly.
I just did I didn't know they named you that. Oh yeah, I went
on stream and I was like, dude, they're they're like gonna get
rolled over. It's crazy.
Um anyway, so where where are we getting to? Oh, the number.
And yeah, where do you stop it? Basically, people there's like
a there's like a real tangible harm in the world that you're
causing, which is like Israel's caused insanely more harm than
Hamas has. Okay. Well, two two goins at least. Like like an insane
amount of harm. But it's like, well, but like we can point to
the Hamas charter, so like we have to eradicate Hamas. And it's
like, dude, you you understand there has to be a limit to that,
right? And now we've seen what happens when there isn't a limit
to that where you just argue like, well, they just wanted to
genocide Jews. They just want to genocide Jews. It's like, okay,
I guess this you're using it to to rationalize what I think is
starting to get closer to something like a genocide at this point.
None of the countries around Gaza want Palestinian refugees.
Yeah, I was suggesting like basically you need to come up with
new ways to get people out. You need to get other countries to
take them. The US should be in a full-on political like uh fullcourt
press trying to get any country they can to take as many of these
refugees as possible to get them just out of the the line of
destruction that Israel is about to cause. It isn't as destroyed
as people made it out to be. Okay, let's take a look. Okay, now
hold on. When I go to see Gaza and I go to zoom in on stuff,
it's not as destroy. I just zoomed on a random area. That's so
right now, dude. I zoomed out and then I zoomed in on a random
area and it's like, dude, every building is here. Everything
is What do you mean it's not as destroyed? I just zoomed in on
a random area. This is insane devastation. The are you talking
about? It's not as destroyed as they thought. What the who what
highers like me this visa? F A FD F A SDF.
Are you high? Have you tasted Trump's scrotum today? What? How
disconnected from reality are you? Dude, it's not really destroyed.
It's actually way better than you thought. Oh my god. Look. Oh
my god. There's like there's a collection of 10 buildings. Oh
my god. These ones are Look, it's more
Are you taking a vacation here, dude? Dude, Bank of Jerusalem.
I see I see build I see buildings still standing. There are some
buildings still standing. I don't think it's that every structure
has been destroyed. I do think that it's like every is it like
every um playground. Let's zoom in on the playground. How's the
playground doing? That playground don't exist no more. That playground
is Yeah. Use your
dude. In all seriousness, it was weird how much was argued in
technicality and how this one country should resist against America
backed country with all the weapons. Then I couldn't get behind
human shields argument. Like what do you do when someone has
a shield? Go around it. Um, sure. It's there's just limited limits
to these things, right? Like at some point you have to say, "Okay,
Hamas is going to be like kind of safe over here because we don't
want to people, right?" Eventually, dude, was this a what was
this? This just looks like a refugee camp. Mosque, Palestine
Square, electronic store. Okay. Jabalia refugee camp market.
Okay. Yo, this place is B. This place is so not destroyed at
all. This place is so awesome. Kenny, you ready to go on vacation?
Yeah, I'm ready. You ready? You ready? Yeah, I'm totally ready.
Crazy. Maybe it's not that bad in comparison to like I don't
know. Yeah, guys, it's not that bad considering like just think
about it. Uh, think about Raqqa compared to like Raqqa. Oh my
god, isn't it better than Raqqa where Russia just shelled that
city until it doesn't exist anymore? It's literally better than
the Russian war crimes. Okay, it's better than Raqqa. Oh my god,
guys. It's so good. Amazing. I'm so psyched. Okay. Anyway, what
even was the point here? Oh, that the the So, basically, you
can't I don't think you can just look at the intent of the group.
Okay. Like, if this was a group of deformed like babies that
had, you know, human brains and had genocidal intent towards
Jews, I don't think that group of babies being kept underground
somewhere in this entirety of Gaza would justify like nuking
Gaza like this. Okay? That's just not You have to You have to
have some consideration for how much harm they can cause. Also,
this is all to say like you're focused on Hamas. You're not focused
on PI. You're not focused on any of the other Islamic terrorist
groups that are in here, right? Any of the other like political
groups, militant groups. Trust me, all of these groups hate you
completely. They they despise you people. Uh, hi. Oh, you hating
Lux Taco in here? Uh, we are kind of We're watching the A Cheeto
debate right now. Oh, nice. Yeah, they have power. They might
cause a genocide. Yeah, I know. But it's like, dude, even if
you get rid of all of them, if you have to all of them, you're
just gonna create another group. This is like this is what we
know. This has just played out so many times. It's crazy.
We're talking about Hassan Piker's lies. Yeah. So, it's for leverage.
Yeah. Essentially. Okay. All of the many, many lies can just
list off the top of their head every time. But, uh, anywh who,
so that is more or less the argument. They said, "If you would
have given back the hostages and surrendered, the war would stop."
Now, the Palestinians in Gaza protested Hamas because Gaza got
whacked pretty hard. So, they were pro. We're just looking through
the I don't know if you saw the Google Earth link from Gaza.
Whacked pretty hard. Do you know what Hamas's response was to
the Palestinian people that they were fighting to quote unquote
liberate? You know what they did? What did they do? They murdered
the leaders of the protest and they dropped the fam the bodies
of those on the doorstep of their families as a warning not to
protest against kamas. Wow. You know what I think we should do?
We should kill 10,000 more of those people who are protesting
of in Palestine in Gaza. So like but it was like the people that
they're claiming to defend. That's kind of what I'm saying. They're
only claiming to defend them. Hold on. McDono Ramus Prime. Thank
you for the gifted sub. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. As far
as like clout goes, they're monsters. They murdered the Palestinian
protesters. They they are they are power- hungry sick of even
though they're claiming to represent them. I just I just I'm
going to go out to this one more time. Gaza war casualties. So,
so there are was it power hungry sickopantic terrorist group?
Could we think of any other groups that are power hungry and
sickopantic and may have engaged something people labeled as
terrorism at all? any
any other controlling force in a country United States similar
region. Oh, wow. I wasn't even going with that one, but sure.
I know. I know you got your eyes squarely focused on the Jews
right now. Okay. I'm trying to I'm trying to be okay here at
the end of the day. All right. I don't have the pass. I can't
go. Wait, I'm Jewish. I I can say whatever I want. Whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. I I didn't mean all Jews, okay? I I meant
a specific ideology in a specific country. Okay. Uh-huh. Let's
take it easy. I just want to go look up the uh what's the ratio
at this point? Okay, here it is. 1,200 dead, Israeli invasion,
80% civilians. Oh boy, it seems like a lot of people have died
here, guys. Like, is it 50 to1 or 100 to1? Really bad, guys.
This seems pretty bad, guys. What is the ratio we go with that?
Like, is it is it 50 to1 in terms of civilians killed? Can we
do 50 to1? 50 Palestinians killed for one Jewish person. Can
we call it even there? Anyway, I'm just talking about how this
whole this whole idea that like while Hamas exists and they have
like genocidal intent towards Jews, we can't like let them we
can't like let them go. You can't take your boot off their neck
and stop bombing the out of civilian infrastructure.
Yeah. It's like we've I I just love that. I argued this in like
November. I argued this with people in like November of 2023.
December. Like on stream. I had whole streams with it with Lyken
and like a bunch of other DG people all coming in. And I thought
this argument was insane. And then we run it out to hypotheticals.
It's like, well, okay, 20,000, 10,000 people. People be like,
no, at 10,000 you'd like have to stop. It's like, dude, we've
hit 70 now. I think we've hit 70. Yeah, we've hit 70. It's like,
dude, there's no stopping because you have this idea. Sorry,
sorry, sorry. Are those reported by the Gaza Health Ministry?
Uh, yeah. I mean, um, Netanyahu, you know, you know, you know
they're Hamas.
You know, that's right. No way. donated $3. Let him move. You're
trusting almost like run the government or something. Wait, wait.
You're trusting right now? Really? Uh yeah. Yeah. Um and I mean
Netanyahu's got it I think like 55,000 as of I did a a stream
the other day and we we went over it was like 55,000 as of a
couple days ago. Google Earth updated their last images of Gaza
to last December. Their images. Oh, so they Wait, are they going
back three days ago? A few months ago in January, I posted on
this sub when Google updated uh images to early November 2023.
The damage was extensive, but I was definitely cherrypicking
the worst areas. Now, their images available from 13 months later,
and the scale of destruction is almost incomprehensible. It is,
it is crazy just literally like moving around and stuff. Oh,
the comparisons before and after are perfectly They're very nice.
Oh my god. Cool. Somebody came into chat was like, "Look, there's
it's like all updated. You should look now." And it's like, wait,
what? No, it's not. I zoom in on a random area. It's like 80%
destroyed, dude.
They can rebuild. God. Anyway, yes. So, I think I think we have
to calibrate our responses and our our what would you call it?
Um our future action based on the actual threat, the actual real
world threat of the group and not just their intent because that
can go on forever. And also depending on how heavily you try
to put your boot down on their neck, you're just creating more
of that intent in other groups that might not have been there
before. So GG one second. The the crazy part is just constantly
using the charter, constantly going back to the founding charter
and always using that to prove the genocidal intent. It's just
like soing tired. Oh, what did you say about genocidal intent
there? Uh it's so annoying that just like KN will constantly
lean on the founding charter to prove genocidal intent. It's
like dude, how long ago was this revised? It's like can we like
take a bit more of a Well, I'm sure you wouldn't take, you know,
go for it. I just wouldn't argue against genocidal intent on
the part of Hamas. Well, no, I wouldn't argue I wouldn't argue
against genocidal intent. I wouldn't argue against genocidal
intent on the Israeli side either, though. And the the um but
it seems like KN will firmly argue no, there's no genocidal intent
on the Israeli side. But then also firmly argue there's definitely
genocide intent on the Hamas side. And the the only way he's
proving that is with a founding charter that that was revised
ages ago. Uh it was not revised as far as I know. It was uh there
was an addendum added to it. Oh, addendum. Sorry. As far as I
know, the previous the previous Yeah, revision means like possibly.
But the previous like comments about Jews are not taken out.
They're still there. All right. Well, that was an addendum made
then. Sorry. What was the addendum say then? Cuz what I'm saying
was change the actually don't know. I just know the stuff about
every Jew. Every Jew hiding behind the tree and all of that.
There's a hadith like quoted in it, I believe. I dude this is
like this getting on close to two years ago now. We're 5 months
away from the 2-year anniversary. Okay. In 2017, I mean, Wikipedia
says a 2017 document removed the antiic language and stated Hamas's
fight was not with Jews
uh as such because of their religion, but with the Zionist project.
It's 2017 apparently. Okay. Uh as far as I know, so I've watched
like Litterbox went through it and it was like an addendum like
they hadn't taken the stuff out. But that was what I remember
watching Lerbox bring up on his stream and I've seen him make
that point like eight times. I feel like I've looked it up myself
and seen that that it wasn't necessarily it wasn't a revision.
Um, but I do think they did specify about the Zionist Project,
but they didn't remove as far as I know the previous stuff, but
I know it's been reported that way. Okay. You're saying still
quotes the hadith, but but has an addendum saying it's about
the Zionist Project basically. Uh, okay. Is that I'm asking is
that what you're saying or that is my understanding. Yeah. That
it's it updates, but it's um it keeps the hadith in and it keeps
uh I think there's other stuff in there about Jews, too. But
we'll we can just look it up at some point. Maybe not right now.
Although I every time I say that I have to like make a decision
now because every time I say maybe we'll look it up. I either
need to look it up now or never look it up cuz I or just admit
that I'll never look it up cuz if I don't look it up right now,
I'm not going to care later. But I'm going to keep watching the
content cuz I want to watch the content. So if they if the people
that they hurt basically said we don't want you to represent
us, they killed them. Yeah. Yeah. Basically. Yeah. Wow. Okay.
That's disturbing. Uh yeah. And can you believe Hamas, these
evil people, they did this. I just found out about I just found
out about illegal Palestine. That man damn, bro. Thanks to GI.
And Hassan supports these guys. He claims he supports, you know,
Palestine, but he supports Hamas, the terrorists that And that
I know. And that I know. I mean, he he doesn't he's not koi about
it. I mean, he's very open and abrasive when he says that he
supports it. And look, I mean, for what it's worth, I don't you
know, Dr. Knox. Yeah. Instantly. Yeah. I I'm never going to fault
him for being
uh elusive about his own beliefs or or hiding what his true beliefs
are because
I'm I'm literally just going to ask him about some of Israel's
actions. Knox, let's do a quick Sabrin Chhatilla rundown. Okay.
Wait, you uh Hold on. How many people were How many people Have
you heard him try and recount the history yet? No. Oh my god.
Sabrin Chhatilla rundown and then Wait, you you took the guy
who ran this whole campaign who made this all happen? who set
it all up and and put it into effect and protected it so it could
happen. And then you made that guy prime minister. Oh, well,
I kind of see why these people might hate you actually. It's
starting to make some sense here. Oh, wait. He was like the third
terrorist you made prime minister. Oh, yeah. Wait, well, I'm
seeing why you guys have tough relations now. I think he is pretty
honest about it. Um, like he has said, you know, I support, you
know, the Houthis. I support Hamas. And then there's the clip
of the the black. I don't think he said I support Hamas, has
he? Uh he's definitely Hold on. You know exactly what that is,
right? When he says like don't dodge, don't let them like make
you let you denounce when when he doesn't denounce. Are they
referring to that? Are they referring to that? They are refusing.
They're referring to instances of that because it looks horrible
for him. He is like the worst at optics around that. Yeah. Well,
I've never seen him say I support Hamas. I've never seen him
say that or anything that is like, you know, along that exact
line. Obviously, he said things like active resistance, I'm sure,
but I don't as a group or anything. I would say Hamas is an awesome
group. Then he said, I'll give you two to one odds. I'll give
you two to one odds on a bet that I believe Hassan has uttered
the words in this direct order. I of course I support Hamas,
but I don't know. I'm saying but like if we had to bet on it,
I feel like I'd put um I'll give you I I I'd do $10 on that 100%.
Okay. So, I'll pay you 20 or you pay me 10. Okay. I just I feel
like
100%. Yeah. I I feel like we'll probably be able to find the
clip pretty quickly if it exists. I'm just saying I But like
that's that's where I would put it. So I don't know, but like
I had to bet, right? I feel like I would
he's more of a Houthies guy. Uh he definitely by the way um we'll
call it a wash if he's done it before October 7th. Okay. Oh god.
Cuz I feel like the real the Do you know what I mean? I I'm not
gonna take your money if he did said it before October 7th because
then he almost certainly said it before October 7th said how
a Jew hitting Hamas loving streamer seduced the New York Times.
Have you seen this dude? I'm opposing. This is like serious.
Hold on. Hold on. Where is uh recommended? This is what I get
on this random website.
Honestreporting.com. Honestreporting.com
at the top of my Oh my god. Is that a Dman special? What is that?
honestreporting.com. Send us your tips. Hamas tunnels of terror,
bro. I I don't Dude, I don't want to make comments, man. I feel
so goofy making comments, but I'm just like, dude, I've never
seen more obvious Zinus propaganda in my life. You buy a website
called honest honestreporting.com. I'm sorry. Oh, brah, what
are you doing? Boosted at some point. We could read it at some
point. Oh my god. I I got 25 minutes into this video and I just
wanted to like actually shove nails in my eyes. I couldn't do
it anymore. I don't think we're ever going back to that, guys.
I don't think I can do it, dude. This guy needs to This guy needs
to be um terrible with his career. He needs If he returns to
Canada, we need to reinstitute capital punishment for treason.
This guy is the worst person. Get him out. I said that's why
I put the Mounty costume on because we took his papers. He didn't
get to be here anymore. I I can't find a clip of Assan saying
that he's sports. I can't even see a Reddit thread of Hassan
says he sports a mouse. I can't I can't I can't see Hassan saying
he sports a mouse. Okay. Uh I will give you I I will give you
24 hours to find this clip. 24 hours. Okay. I mean I'm going
to take 48. 48. Okay. 48. 48. No problem. Okay. Honest reporting
or honest reporting is an Israeli media advocacy group, a pro-Israel
media watchdog. It describes its mission as combating ideological
prejudice in journalism and media as it impacts Israel. Wow.
Wow. Shocking. I'm It sucks when I say something and I'm like,
I think I'm gonna get called racist for this, but it is just
the most obvious like Zionist Hasbro I've ever seen. And then
it just is every time. What am I supposed to do when it just
is? Stop noticing, J. They hate when you notice. Why you did
an interview with Hamas in the tunnels? We've already got a lot
of content here, Travis Lamb. We're trying to get through it.
Okay. My god. The the one he's like half black streamer NMP NMP
lol when he's with him and he basically says, "Are these guys
the like terrorists?" And then he's like the America calls him
terrorists and if you want to call him that then yeah. So actually
that was uh referring to Hezbollah not kamas. Okay. So Hezbollah
is okay. So um imagine this. Israel is a really tiny plot of
land um surrounded by a lot of um Arab states
directly at the bottom of Israel there's Gaza at the south and
at uh Okay. So I feel like I got to do a little history lesson.
No, I mean and this will be good for people who don't who are
not fully aware. I'm here for it. The Knucks Taku
there. Yes, surely.
Dude, I'd love to. Okay, he should have he should have queued
this up and then it's like, okay, now tell me the history of
indigenous peoples in Canada. Tell me what happened to those
guys. Okay, aware of it, right? Like, why is commentary only
about politics now? Well, I think what's hap Sorry, don't I just
want to That's a great Oh my god. I wonder what chatter said
that. Hold on. Can I find that chatter? Where is it? Why is Tony
Martinez? Why is commentary only about politics now? Yes, these
people should be talking about whatever mcrafter raped another
mcrafter. Okay, that's what they're qualified for. I've said
this a hundred times tonight, Quayman. But it's like if I want
opinions on the best, I'll go to Noox Taku. But I want political
opinions. I'll talk to somebody who's followed politics for more
than three months. Okay. I don't want I don't want his political
opinions. I don't need them. He's got no qualifications. He doesn't
understand what what to even look for. Explain what I think.
I think that by the way that's just me saying I'll never want
to talk to this guy. Okay, just to be clear commentary what when
we look at like the 2016 cringe culture stuff that was like innocent
you know someone like Pokemon Go kid is cringe okay 10 million
views I think we've since called that stuff very lowbrow and
so we have to justify making content where we on others and the
justification that's used now has been deemed by the public as
justifiable which is that people have like audacious political
views you know and that's just what it is and I think it is a
good justification I think if you look at someone and you look
at their political views and how they use these views to connect
with people, you can on them. I think that's fair, you know.
I mean, it does suck from from like an entertainment perspective
that, you know, you know, commentary is politics now, but at
the same time like the world is politics. If you look at the
polarization, it's never been higher. So, it's the stuff that
people actually care about the most. Sorry to Well, I mean I
I also kind of feel like um if you're trying to do drama like
people content, you want to criticize a streamer, you kind of
have to know what the streamer is talking about and all the lies
streamer propagates. Mhm.
No, you don't say. No, of course knows what he's talking about.
Oh, bro, I there were just in that 25 minute 25 minutes I watched
of this video, he's just wrong like a thousand times in a row.
Like literally, it's like I you can't get through it. is just
all wrong.
Whoa. And it's so crazy. And and then the opinions are like the
most like he he does no arguing for his opinions. He basically
just goes, "Oh yeah, I think that's based cuz of the lips." It's
like, "Okay, this is the deal out, dude." Yeah. Trump is like
being super nice to Cardi. He's art of the deal, guys. Cardi
is like says one nice thing to Trump. He's like, "Look at him
bowing before Trump. Oh my god, he's so pathetic. I can't believe
Canadians voted for this guy's like, "Dude, get him out of my
country. Never let him back in." Whoops, wrong video. I don't
want to watch this anymore. I need to close it. Yeah, 100%. Yeah,
100%. So, uh, Gaza, for example, it was So, in 1967, there was
a there was a war called the Six-Day War. It was where, um, uh,
five countries around Israel, uh, five Arab countries attacked
Israel. Basically, Israel started that war off with a surprise
attack on Egypt. Actually, did you point that out, Cleman? That's
literally one of the most famous effective surprise attacks of
all time. That's they literally they literally bombed the Syrian
and Egyptian air forces at the same time. They like actually
wiped out their the entirety of their air forces. I don't understand
how you could possibly say all of these countries attacked Israel.
Israel started it with a preemptive strike. I had this up the
other night. Operation is it focus or echo? I think it's focus.
Well, Jason, it was a preemptive strike. So, they knew the war
was going to start. So, the others actually started it. They
had we don't have to put any of the information any other information
to be fair. Yeah, I know. But but it's like the idea that you
you just you just present it as though the other side started
it. Like even if there is they did have intel, you should still
present it as well, Israel started the war by launching a preemptive
strike because they had intel that suggested they were going
to be attacked. You shouldn't present it as oh no the Arabs started
the war. It's like no that's not what happened is it strike [__]
I think what actually happened was they got basically intel that
like these countries probably were discussing doing something
right. They they they were discussing doing something and they
had their air forces completely exposed and they were like you
know what if we go right now we actually these people up like
horribly and they're like yeah risk it right if if it's going
to turn into a war eventually we can take out like half of their
jets yeah let's do it. So yeah operation focus was the opening
air strike by Israel at the start of the six day war. It is sometimes
referred to as the CNI air strike at 7:45 June 5th 1967. The
IIAF under Morai HUD launched a massive air strike that destroyed
the majority of the Egyptian air force on the ground. Following
Syrian and Jordanian attacks and retaliation, the Israeli air
force proceeded to bomb air bases in those countries. By noon,
the Egyptian, Jordanian, and Syrian air forces, totaling about
450 aircraft were destroyed. It was also very successful in disabling
18 airfields in Egypt, hindering Egyptian air operations for
the duration of the war, and remains one of the most successful
air attack campaigns in military history. This is literally when
they realized, "Oh, wait. We actually should put like um reinforcements
over top of our aircraft. We can't just leave these all these
aircraft sitting out in a field somewhere. We should actually
put them in like some kind of like reinforced bunker so that
they won't get bombed." Oh my god. Let go. But yeah, 450 aircraft.
Israel only had 200 aircraft and they destroyed 450 in this afternoon.
The war was won initially with this strike. So anyway, suffice
to say Naku just made some up some crazy some wild. Okay. And
I think Resi came in and said yes, there were people mustering
and u there was there was some idea that like Siri wanted to
do something. They It wasn't like they totally made it up. There
probably was going to be some kind of conflict. Yes. But I think
to me I don't think they had absolute proof that conflict was
coming or that a war was starting. And I think they they just
realized that hey, we can actually end their ability to fight
us with without like and we're going to take that opportunity
and normally it doesn't matter to N presentation of it anyway
cuz N has totally dishonestly presented it whether they or not
cuz Yeah. I mean you shouldn't start as present as one side starting
if they didn't. It's insane. Well, yeah, when there's an opening
air strike that is like famous. Yeah. Right. Countries around
Israel. Uh five Arab countries attacked Israel. Basically, Israel
pushed them back. They ended up winning the war. They ended up
pushing them like south deep in He is confusing. He is mixing
48 and 67 is what he's doing right now 100%.
Right. You could make this You could make this claim for 48 that
like they they attacked and they got pushed back. But he's just
confusing 48 and 67. 67. It's literally called the six- day war.
How much retreating could Israel have possibly done that they
retreated for six days into Egypt. They gave that land back except
for Gaza which Israel kept at the time. So, um, at that time
there was a mixed Yeah. six- day war and they captured all of
uh the Goollet Heights and the Sinai Peninsula ethnicities in
Gaza. Essentially, there was a a small minority of Jewish people
living in Gaza. Your stream just went black. Yeah. Yeah. My camera.
Sorry. Okay. And uh at that and in around 2005, they decided,
you know, uh Sinai, Brazilian, Sinai, [__] You know
what? were going to be giving Gaza to the Palestinians as a place
for them that all the Jews were um told to leave Gaza. They pulled
them out um and they said, "We're going to give this spot as
a uh like as a peace treaty." And they made a deal with them
that you'll keep Gaza and we will uh we'll be homies. We'll be
besties. Um as far as 3,000 years of beef goes, they were not
homies and besties. Uh since in 2005, they actually elected Kamas.
Hamas was is there 3,000 years of beef? What do you mean 3,000
when was m when was Islam founded in like 350 AD or something?
What do you mean 3,000 years of beef?
That's when he was promised Israel. You
Um by Gaza became a radical terrorist group that since 2005 fired
around 11,000 missiles into civilian cities in Israel. Mhm. Um
uh and we missed a lot of stuff there in the middle. There's
a whole bunch of stuff there in the middle that we've just skipped
entirely. It culminated in this October 7, 2023. Listen, the
Jews got attacked twice, 4867. They got pushed back both times
and then eventually won. And then they gave land back because
they are the the they are the absolute they the the most kind,
loving people. They gave all the land back. Okay. And then Hamas
radicalized and started launching rockets at us and there was
nothing we could do about it. My god war that they jumped over
the wall, they attacked Israel and they killed like 1,200 civilians,
right? Was this the short of it? This is while they they're in
charge of the government, right? They're in charge of the government.
Okay. And so what I'm trying to understand is that um wouldn't
there be some benefit for like regime change like ASAP, right?
They don't want regime change, right? Well, obviously they're
not Yeah. Literally 15 minutes before this in the same thing,
he was saying the civilians were arguing against Hamas. Yeah.
Hamas doesn't want regime change. Turns out the the regime in
power never wants regime change. But the Palestinians you just
said were were protesting them. So I don't know what the he's
saying. Not a democracy. But like not anymore. They were elected
in 2005 and they uh they basically controlled the area since
then. Anyone that sp Okay. So let me tell you something. The
guy that orchestrated are they democracy? I'm talking about I
don't know if they're democracy. I assume not. Yeah. No, not
right now for sure. Okay. Um so uh the guy that orchestrated
October 7th was a terrorist named Yaha Sinoir. He's dead. May
he rot in hell. So, uh, that guy, um, insanely enough was known
as the butcher of Khan Ununas because apparently he murdered
any Palestinian voice that went up against him. Um, like he he
was a real a real monster, that guy. Okay. Like he killed he
killed anyone that he didn't like. Right. Right. Okay.
Um, so that's Gaza and Hamas. Now, little history lesson. Gotcha.
Little history lesson. At the north of Israel, there's the country
Lebanon. Southern Lebanon is the host of Hezbollah, another terrorist
organization. They were in uh being controlled by Nasra. And
that's the one. They're very musical people. Yeah. Nope. That's
the Houthies. Oh, that's the Houthis. They're a terrorist organization
based in Yemen. Okay. So, NASA, there's so many I can't keep
track. He likes all of them, though. That's sort of He likes
all of them. He somehow he likes all of them. Okay. Gotcha. Yes.
Yes. Yes. Yeah. So, uh, Sinir, not Sinwart, that's Kamas. Nasalla
is the terrorist that that was in charge of, um, things aren't
this simple, but like if you're operating on NX's level of simplicity
here, he'd just say that Hassan would say something like he likes
the people who don't like genocide. That's what he would say,
right? Oh, true. Operate on level of simplicity. Like, that's
Yeah, I don't know. Goofy. Hezbollah in southern Lebanon. So
those guys
Nasala Hassan Nasala. So that's the guy that has your entirely
[__] It is a cheetah [__] No, that would
probably be my Is it coming through on stream totally or what?
Is stream good? He's super smart. He reads so many books.
Okay, it's definitely going to be [__] for you guys,
too. Hold on. Uh it it's just I think I should just have to restart
my stream. It should be fine. Audio is good for stream anyway.
So you guys tell me if that's better. He's not even anti-Semitic,
bro. That's a new one. He said that he's not even anti-Semitic.
Now, Hala is known for quotes like I want all this is this is
actually where I would have gone first. So, I got linked a clip.
Okay. Systems of oppression. Why are you avoiding why you avoiding
over the center? You do it, too. I'm not avoiding it. I've talked
about it a million times. Let me ask you this. This is not where
we're hang Let me just ask you. Let me just ask. Let me ask you
one more time. Do you believe what happened on October the 7th
was a justified act of revolution? Yes or no? I do not. And I
do think that I Oh, wait. Hold on. That's Let me Let me clarify.
Let me clarify something very important here. Events that unfolded
on October 7 were atrocities. That much is clear. Those atrocities
could have been avoided if Israel was not an aparttheid regime.
Israel has been an apartheid
regime. You keep repeating. I got l this time stamp and it was
like this is this is me weighing in on the bet. You can't just
chime in. You can't just chime in. You ask me a question. You
want to You ask me a question. I'm going to give you an answer
cuz you're repeating. Israel has been an aparttheid regime since
its inception. Until until
1967, Israel was an apartheid regime. I feel bad on pan. He said
I do not. Oh,
on. Systems of oppression.
Oh, you just didn't give me a good time stamp. No, no, he gave
me if he's saying I I do not October 7th. Right. Yeah. Yeah.
I didn't think he supported October 7th. I thought he supported
Hamas or he has supported Hamas at some point in the past. Right.
Right. But it wouldn't be supporting October 7th. I don't think
he's out here like the murdering and of civilians. I've never
thought about sure. Yeah, there's a difference. Oh, okay. Never
mind. I got to evaluate my Jews in the world to move to Israel
so that when I'm going to back up like he's not uh he's not even
anti-Semitic, bro. That's his new one. He says that he's not
even anti-semitic. Now, Hala is known for quotes like I want
all Jews in the world. Yeah. To be clear, I did not say that
Hassan would have supported October 7th. I just feel like he's
probably said, "Yeah, of course I support like Hamas in like
this thing." I thought those words, those explicit words would
have left his mouth, but maybe not. To move to Israel so that
when we kill all the Jews in Israel, we get all the Jews at the
same time. Um, that's something that Nasala the terrorist said.
So when what a what a great concept. I love when my enemies collect
together. Really genius person might use that for another thing.
Okay. The son says that that guy's not anti-semitic.
Um, that's not exactly accurate. Okay. Well, if that's one of
his quotes, then I probably would say that that's uh you know,
not the friendliest towards Jewish people for sure. And so he's
is he I think didn't didn't Nasella I think Nasella went even
beyond that. I think NSA said something like uh like I hate Jews.
And just to be clear, so we don't do the racist thing and conflate
Zionist and Jew. No, I mean Jews. I'm pretty sure that's like
the level Nost Nostril I was operating on. Like I don't want
I don't want you to get confused and think I just hate Zionists.
You sure this guy sounds awesome? Is he alive still? No, he's
dead. They killed him. Okay, gotcha. So So he he was part of
Hezbollah, correct? He was the leader of Hezbollah. Okay. Uh
Hezbollah also, by the way, contributed to the murders of uh
over 600,000 people in Syria. Okay. Gotcha. All right. So I just
want to circle back to Hassan real quick because I think when
you look at all the conflict and the history, we got a little
unfocused there for a second. started talking about some figures
in the region. I need to get focused over on Hassan again. Can
we please talk about Hassan more? He's clearly chosen a side
and you've clearly chosen a side and they're diametrically opposed
and I want to look at necess I want to magnify and glass the
recent stuff that he's done that you were talking about, right,
which was that he was talking about the US report. And if you
want to go into anything around that, feel free get sidetracked.
If there's if this reminds you of like another thing that he
said about like a different group, then go off on that. I want
to dissect specifically because when I was watching your stream
with Tech Tone, that's what you were saying and I'm like, damn,
this guy knows his stuff. He came prepared and so
just just the Dan the Dan Naku stream. Oh boy. Uhoh. Uhoh, dude.
Just just the floor is yours, right? Like just you know. Yeah.
Well, um Okay. So, I don't know. Do you want Do you want me to
send you the UN report? Well, let's let's get right into it.
Yeah, let's let's let's do it. Okay, so I sent it to you. Basically,
Hassan has been doing this thing on his streams where essentially
he has been um he has been denying the of women if they are Israeli
women. Um that's kind of been his move. Like anytime someone
brings up October 7th, he will laugh and they'll be like, "Oh,
oh, that didn't happen." Like, what are we talking about? Sorry,
real quick. Do you think there's any way that you could um like
share it on your screen or something? cuz there's no way for
me to really have it up. Wait, what? We're not sure if Teone
is a good ally. Bad optics. Wait, what? What do you mean?
Techone. He's a retire. No, no, no. We don't know that he's a
We know it's true. It's true. He's only accused. He's not He's
not He might not actually be a He's only accused. I would just
say that there seems to be a prevalence in the bloodline. That's
all. And yeah, he's accused and there seems to be a history in
his family. Okay. No, imag the chat just bad optics. What?
Read that. Isn't Tech kind of a weird guy? I'm not sure a good
ally. Bad optics. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Optics. Why
is that? Techone is He's fine. What's his problem? What's your
problem with Techone? I mean, that's, you know, someone made
um valations against him without evidence. Okay. I don't know
if it happened or didn't happen, but there's no evidence, so
I'm not going to Aren't the optics worse if you're saying that
I have bad optics? Like, aren't you siding with that by extension?
Dude, I don't know why they they changed something with the the
layout. Can I not screen share two at the same time? Cuz my VTuber
thing is on a screen share. Gotcha. Um,
you you can take No, you need a virtual camera. Um, can he just
screen share and watch his own screen share? Even though we're
talking about the US or sorry, even though we're talking about
Israel Palestine, even the US considers the Taliban as a terrorist
organization. Isn't it isn't one now since the government ruler
of as of Afghanistan. Yeah, that's unrelated. Sorry. Continue.
Okay, I pulled up your stream because you had my thing open.
Give me a second.
That's sad. I from um this is the uh open up this entire report
done for the October 7th terrorist attacks.
Um, it's very long. Assan probably didn't read it. Please, but
like you can just look at some of them. I I'll I'll show you
some. So, that's a picture. It's definitely a drawn image of
a of a child in a compromised position. Whatever that picture
is. Remember, Hassan looks at this showed this conclusion, right?
This uh the conclusion here.
Uh well, Ethan showed it on their debate and he's like, "Yeah,
of course I know about this already. It's just circumstantial
evidence. There's no actual that the terror is anybody, right?
Interesting.
I do. We have to go to the actual clip of the this part of the
stream. It's just not quite what you said, is it? It's like I
just hate cuz what Hassan's saying is
technically true. The point that it's circumstantial, not forensic,
right? The evidence was not collected forensically. And it says
in the report that the evidence was not collected forensically.
Now, obviously, you can draw a pretty firm conclusion about what
happened here from some of the evidence. It's not like this is
like totally up in the air. We can't prove anything as I think.
Yeah. Which I think he tries to we talked about this last night,
but I think Yeah, he tries to walk he tries to walk a little
bit of he tries to walk a line. He definitely tries to walk a
line on it, but Knox clearly does not have the intelligence,
doesn't have the knowledge, does not have even the the uh mental
capacity to engage with the talking point well enough to actually
debunk it in in the form it's spoken or meant. And it's so annoying
just hearing people endlessly go, "Oh yeah, Hassan just doesn't
believe anything in this report." That's not what he thinks.
That's not what he says ever. Sure. That it's like it's more
subtle than that. So you just don't like that the criticism is
like so habfisted because they're too lazy to make it correctly,
right? Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Yeah, I can see that. Yeah. So the conclusion
is overall based on the totality of information gathered from
multiple and independent sources at the different locations,
there are responsible grounds to believe that the conflict related
violence occurred at several locations across the Gaza periphery,
including in the form of gang during the October 7th attacks.
credible
circumstances, oh, you think I'm deny like, yeah, I think you
deny goes, okay, what do I deny? Uh, will you deny the UN preliminary
report? No, I don't. I've always accepted the UN preliminary
report. I've always accepted findings of that. Oh, like where
does this guy go? Where's He's totally ripped at that point.
No, he doesn't have the he would be with this exact line of argumentation.
Yeah, you need more. You need Hassan's basically like the I believe
it was a retweet of the squirrel or maybe he just pulled it up
on stream. I'm actually not sure. So, you need the the squirrel
stuff to like basically say and you need like active support
from him. So, I don't remember exactly what he did with those
tweets. If he retweeted, I feel like that's uh I feel like that's
a dicey one. I won't necessarily hold most people responsible
for their retweets, but um that person's a squirrel person. And
then yeah, kind of looking at what he says on his stream, too.
But it it just takes work and that's not something Nux is going
to put into this at all. So no definitely just, you know, watched
maybe the maybe watched like the content nuke and a couple other
things and he's just got the same talking points. So yeah, he
just watch. It's like, yeah, it's basically some form of violence
including genital mutilation, torture, cruel and human degrading
treatment was also gathered. So he he's denying that there were
basically. So this is the conclusion. He's denying that it happened.
Uh, and he's saying, "Well, even though the conclusion says it
probably happened, it's just circumstantial information, so we
can't actually believe it. Pixar, it didn't happen, bro." Right?
That's the uh that's the guy literally just gag got talking points.
Good times. Son argument. Pixer it didn't happen. Um because
it's only circumstantial. And why would he believe circumstantial
information? Now, something you may not be aware of. Uh that
doesn't matter. You know why that doesn't matter? Because lots
of people on Twitter are saying that's what he said. So he's
ra I know. Yeah, that's how it is. Circum circumstantial meaning.
Wait, wait, wait. Was that Did I just cut somebody off here?
I just said, but I will always point out that it's not that that's
not true. So yeah, I again I agree with you that it's like not
strictly true. I just agree that or how do I put it? Just isn't.
I I feel like in essence you get like closer with the things
um Nux is saying than just to say like no no it's not true that
he doesn't deny. But I it doesn't mean you can do it either way.
Like it is strictly true. No, it's not. I'm not saying he doesn't
die rape. I'm saying Assan does not reject this report. Assan
does not doubt what this report says. At least in his what verbiage.
He might mentally, who knows? Yeah, but from what he says, he
does not say this report is wrong or I don't believe this or
anything along those lines. He says he points to the fact that
it is circumstantial and not forensic. But he does not say this
is wrong. He does not doubt it. Oh, I'm glad you asked because
that is something he avoided. So, this is the circumstantial
information. Uh here's one for example. You see they um these
are different cities that were attacked and they're all categorized
in in different little uh little parts of the UN report. So,
for example, this one during the attacks on Kibbutar Aza located
3 km from Gaza perimeter fence approximately 50 resident of its
population of 700 were killed when hundreds of militants entered
the Kabuts. These militants are the Hamas terrorists, right?
uh armed with militarygrade weaponry. Most killings were reported
to have occurred in the 12 hours before the IDF were deployed
in the area. Dozens of houses were burned. Fighting between militants
and IDF forces in and around the kibuts, reportedly to have ended
only on the 10th of October, complicating the recovery of bodies.
The mission team collected information from the first responders
who reported discovering bodies of women naked with their hands
tied behind their backs, gunshot wounds in the head. While verification
of violence against these victims was not possible at this point,
right? You have to realize verification means finding [__]
in their vagina. There's no other verification. You can't verify
which they can't really do.
Yeah. Oh, they totally could do it, but it's just uh it's they
totally could do it. They absolutely could. Almost all it's it's
just like it doesn't mean it respecting their religious norms
and then like it's like it's it's annoying, right? cuz it's like
such a I feel like both sides do this point like so poorly where
super pro-Israel people are going to well not even super pro
Israel people anyone slightly pro Israel is like oh wow you so
if they don't disres all their religious norms and allow you
to swab bodies then oh then you just can't believe anything or
whatever the other side is very extreme on that side to be honest
what most people on the other side will say because they haven't
proved it never happened and it's like well there's obviously
see issues with, you know, you would prefer to have a full investigation
that allows you to verify every claim and get the maximum information,
but that doesn't mean you can't believe anything. But also on
the other side, the religious norms are stupid. The idea that
we [__] international like investigations because
of religious norms is like so
like it's so stupid. But people play defense for that. People,
secular people who should probably know better will play defense
for that idea. Yeah. Well, yeah. And I I don't know. I I think
like there's another whole thing there where it's like, well,
what are you gonna do? Like verify like there's some some something
to be said for like the purpose of doing those kinds of forensic
investigations is to like have a trial and hold the people responsible
who are going to do it. And Israel has no interest in like holding
trials for these people, right? Like those people are not going
to continue breathing. So, it's like well, it's sort of a moot
point anyway. Like probably I would imagine 95 to plus percent
of the people who participated in the October 7th attacks are
gone, right? I think I Well, okay. I still just because Israel's
got no interest holding trials for those people doesn't mean
we shouldn't uh do it to gather the information or whatever.
Sure. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But just just to like um you should assume
they're not going to but you should function everything should
operate assuming that like the processes of intentional bodies
and are going to play out properly and if if Hamas people did
war crimes then they will be held accountable in a in a court
and you should operate assuming that to be the case whether the
other party has any intention of letting that happen or not.
Um and you should you judgment should be aiming for that. So,
you shouldn't be saying like, "Oh, it's fine. They've got these
religious norms and we should just not investigate." Yeah, I
am. Um, Pumpernicle in the chat saying that Hamas terrorists
were systemically okay with using lethal violence and violence
on October 7th. Like, it was uh Hold on, I just left my chat
somehow. Like, it
was Okay, I just lost that chat. Whatever. You're saying you
think there was some systemic violence? I don't know if you count
that as systemic violence. Um, sure. I made a good argument about
the systemic thing that or I don't feel I explain this even if
I heard it somewhere else but the lack of a system can cause
systemic uh effects to occur, right? I think that's probably
true and that would be my argument overall is like um yeah that
that would be probably if you have like 17 to 20year-old militants
who are all going to attack like a bunch of these things and
you give them no rules, then there is one thing they're going
to do very likely, right? So sure, you could you could make that
argument. Um I like I would say that the it seems like it occurred
violence occurred across enough venues that that there was nothing
holding it back. They definitely weren't told don't you know
if you wreck you'll be in big trouble that never happened. Evidence
is circumstantial inherently. However, the cir available circumstantial
information. All right. So this is the circumstantial information
that we're talking about that has believed. Notably the recurring
pattern of female victims found undressed, bound and shot indicates
that violence including potential torture, cruel and human degrading
treatment may have occurred. So this is awful obviously and um
there's no way you could read this and think that didn't happen.
Right. Someone in my chat says he also said he didn't push but
it was inevitable. Yeah, I think it's um yeah, it's a combination
of like statements over time. Again, I think I Dude, is there
like a footage of him with the Zcirrel tweet pulled up or something?
I don't know why he lets himself get like lobbed onto the Z scroll
person all the time. If they're okay with executing children,
it seems pretty strange to claim that those same people would
arbitrarily draw the line at it might be my bias, but in circumstances
of October 7th, um I mean, you can say that, but it's about systematic
would mean like a modus operandi, I would say. And I think um
yeah, I don't know. No one's saying they're like they're drawing
a red line. I don't think any anyone's really arguing that. Yeah.
Like systemic would mean directed. To me means directed. Um you
could like if you wanted to say I wouldn't deny that the lack
of a system could be something that ends up with like a systemic
injustice happening. But like I would say that I would need to
like I would just make that point. I wouldn't say that it was
systemic injustice like that it systemic to me just means top
down directed. Right.
No, systemic doesn't mean top down directed because I think systemic
as in like people use systemic racism, right? Which is it that
doesn't require top down direction. That's the that's the idea
of this thing occurring within a system not necessarily of any
individual's bias system.
Uh okay, I get where you're coming from with systemic racism,
but this isn't like a what do you call like a a system that's
sitting there over time. Oh, you know what? I am Hold on. I am
even less just help me out. I am mixing systematic and systemic.
System systemic. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Systematized and systemic
are two different. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Anyway, you can continue
on with both to happen. So, I'll tell you the inevitable clip.
Uh that was um there was a video. Okay. The reason why I said
that one was inevitable is because that was a video. Uh there
was a video where they took a um I think it was a German Israeli
girl, right, that and they um they grabbed her and they threw
her in the back of a truck and um there was a video of all this
happening. This you obviously can't show on stream. Oh. So, um
there was a she was thrown in the back of a truck and she was
naked from the bottom down and there was like blood pouring out
between her legs and uh they kind of paraded her around
um after they brought her back to Gaza and killed her. Right.
Okay. I don't want to be an [__] here. I do not remember
the blood pouring out between her legs. This is Luke. This is
shiny. Everyone Everyone says this. Yeah. I've I've never inspected
the video thoroughly enough to verify the claims. I just ignore
it. Like I do think Shnie was obviously like the girl getting
pulled out of the back of the vehicle was not Shauny Luke though,
Sulfur. So, we're mixing two things. And the girl who got pulled
out of the back of the vehicle was sitting with her with her
um with cuts all over her feet and stuff where she was bleeding,
but she was sitting in like a pool of her own blood. Right. So
I again the girl getting dragged out of the vehicle. I don't
believe she even I don't believe she accused them of rap but
that's my last recollection. I believe um I don't believe there
there was an accusation there but I guess we'd have to look into
it again. You're really denying right now. I believe women I
but but like that I it used to be so easy um to talk about that
cuz it's like I could just say bro this is a bunch of like Arab
terrorists who broke into these kabutzas. I fully believe they
ripped. I just don't think like that girl getting dragged out
of the back of a vehicle. I don't think it's proven that she
she was raped. Sorry. Like I f Yeah, you don't have to convince
me that 17-year-old Arab who's never seen a woman before shows
up to that festival and somebody. You don't have to con I'm being
racist. Okay. Yeah, you don't have to convince me. I believe
it completely, but just that one girl and then the Shiny Luke
girl was dead fairly early. I don't know. Anyway, but they didn't
even there just was no like uh prisoners or hostages, I should
say. Well, they're defin there were hostages. This person was
not a hostage. This person was murdered. Um, right now, so this
person was just like taken and killed like for no reason. Well,
I mean, most of this is this guy not watch any October 7th footage.
Is this guy not traumatizing himself with atrocity? What is he
doing? He's getting his feet wet. Well, define the reason. Whatever
reason you want to give for the rest of it is the reason you
gave for this. Well, I'm saying like specifically the the usage.
You said that she was like in like a a truck, right? It's like
what's the difference between like putting this person in her
to be a hostage, but uh she ended up getting dying. Okay, that's
Yeah, this guy is definitely mixing the girl who with the the
cuts on her ankles that aristocracy said had her um Achilles
cut when she was walking on that foot. But um that girl, they're
complaining that girl.
Oh, hello. Ruben donated $3. Do you think they sing Arabian Nights?
Arabian nights like Arabian days. Uh yeah, possibly. Thank you
very much for the donation. Reven was getting at right because
it's like okay many people just died on the spot. Gun shooted
dead. Okay. That was that was the majority. They killed 12. Exactly.
Exactly. So my my point is is like why was she not a hostage
if they brought her into like a truck? Well, a lot of the hostages
ended up died uh ended up killed in Gaza once they were already
taken. Gotcha. Okay. Like for example, uh there was a family
called the the Bibbas family where they basically they were the
whole family was taken hostages. The mother, the father and the
two children, the two children were ages one and three. Um and
they they released the father released they did a uh a prisoner
swap for with the father. They and um they told the father that
um the rest of them were alive, but it turns out they were not.
Uh they murdered the mother and the two babies in captivity.
Uh and they um they did a coffin dance parading their corpses
out and uh partying over the corpses of the I looked into this
one and it didn't seem like it was proven either way quite what
happened. But obviously, you know, I Yeah, I there was a lot
of stuff going around. It seems like um like I saw from OSN things
and people who are like not affiliated with Israel that like
they're like yeah I've seen some crazy Telegram videos of like
yeah basically people's like heads on pikes in Gaza like from
that night but I've never seen it verified. So again I wouldn't
just say that this happened as if it were fact right. Oh no the
not the coffin dance stuff that there were celebration around
like coffins or some there was video of that. I mean the boss
stuff. Yeah. apparently uh basically uh pretty soon after October
7th um Hamas reported that they had been killed in an airirst
strike and they returned the bodies. So the way N is presenting
is already dised anyway because the way he's presenting is is
as if uh they said they were alive that they were alive the whole
time and he only found out when he got the bodies that they were
actually dead or whatever but when that's not quite what happened
they died pretty soon after October 7th. Hamas said it was an
Israeli air strike. They returned the bodies. uh Israeli Israel
claimed that uh forensic analysis showed that
uh they were killed uh with bare hands and that they the bodies
had been mutilated to appear as though they were killed in an
air strike uh and they were going to share their evidence with
international partners, but I don't think there was ever any
verification on it. Okay. All right. And Assan essentially on
that stream where he reacted to that, he was like laughing and
cheering along with the Hamas terrorists as they paraded around
those coffins. Wait, I didn't think there was footage of the
coffin dancing. Can I get a clip on that? Han dancing. Does he
show it here? Okay. Maybe he does. That's crazy.
um crazy ass. I can show it to you. I made a video. Yeah. Yeah,
sure. Show the clip. I want to see this. Let's see. That seems
like pretty outside anything I would expect from from Hassan.
Him outright like doing aw walk over. If I if I remember what
this is probably, you'll see. When I see Hassan do this, it's
like he's going to go like, "Israel faked this." And then he's
going to like say it, right? And then he'll like laugh. It's
usually not him being like, "Oh yeah, those those Israeli kids
getting killed is so awesome." I won't spoil. I think that's
his thing. I remember I'm sure that it's I'll find it on Twitter.
He was getting tickled. But anyway, I'll show you the inevitable
clip while I'm looking for this one. This is the inevitable that
was uh about the girl that was um murdered, thrown in the back
of the truck and like blood pouring out between her legs and
that you're not seeing the entire picture. Were there brutal,
unjustifiable acts of violence that uh civilians had to endure?
Absolutely. Absolutely. I've seen the videos. I know. I saw the
girl with the dreads in the back of the pickup truck. That is
completely unacceptable. That might not represent the interests
of the Palestinians, but that is violent retribution. That was
an inevitability. It they said it's Yeah. Nothing. Nothing. I
I get how that people off, but represent. It's not what they're
saying it is. Saying it's inevitable is not saying it's deserved.
It's saying it's inevitable. But weren't or I guess if it's not
a democracy. I'll find you. By the way, I can find you like four
Destiny if anybody like really disagrees with it. I can find
four Destiny clips of him saying the same thing that like violence
from Hamas and from Gaza was inevitable. Right. Pretty much nobody
based. Retribution is implying deserved. No, it is not. Pumpernnickel.
It is explicitly not implying it's deserved. Is implying it is
done in retribution as in I was wronged and now I am wronging
you. Retribution maybe. Does retribution imply justified? Hold
on. Retribution. Punishment inflicted on someone is vengeance
for a wrong or criminal act. No, it doesn't imply justified.
So retribution isn't necessarily justified. So, so it doesn't
really matter. Well, when he says it doesn't represent the interests,
like he's arguing, you know, it doesn't represent the interests
of the Palestinians that people are getting raped. Uhhuh. Like,
what? Do you think it does? I don't think it I mean, I don't
think it does. No, of course not. Obviously not.
That's how closely a cheetah is following right now. Wait, you
think uh women does help the Palestinian interests? Oh my god.
Okay, continue. It's violence is unstoppable in that situation.
If all you know is violence, if all you have withstood is violence,
if every single moment of your life is violent, some douchebags
are going to behave in that regard. Uh whereas uh during a a
military operation, you're not seeing the entire picture. Yeah.
So he's saying um because he didn't really say it was inevitable
though, to be fair. He did. He literally said it. Yo, at least
at least moral release in on him again. Jesus Christ. Oh my god,
dude. That morale conversation where you just couldn't fathom
what Moral was saying. Moral was like being so nice to him. I'm
sorry. Moral is like trying to walk him. He's like, I understand
why you're mad, but this is all I'm saying. Cheetah is just losing
it on him. Were brutal unjust. Yeah. I'll show one more time.
Justifiable acts of violence that uh civilians had to endure.
Absolutely. Absolutely. I've seen the [__] videos.
I know. I saw the girl with the dreadjust
speaking through the clips that uh civilians had to endure. Absolutely.
Absolutely. I've seen the videos. I know. I saw the girl with
the dread. Oh, the entire picture. Uh during a a military operation,
you're not seeing the entire picture. Yeah. So, he's saying um
because he didn't really say it was inevitable, though. To be
fair, he did. He literally said it. Were there brutal unjust
Yeah. I'll show one more time. Justifiable acts of violence.
Yeah. Yeah. He said this in the first thing. Yeah. Unjustifiable.
Yeah. That uh civilians had to because things justified when
he says retribution. Well, when he's he literally says this is
retribution. Literally said endure. Absolutely. Absolutely. I've
seen the videos. I know. I saw the girl with the dreads in the
back. Right. So, this is him saying he saw the girl with the
dreads. The video that you were talking about. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Back of the pickup truck. That is completely Why? I just think
it's disgusting that this guy's trying to run like blatant Israel
Husbra and like I'm kind of 40 51 49 like I really go back and
forth between thinking like these people are probably slightly
less monstrous versus the other ones and I know the names like
I I I actually paid attention. How do you do this kind of Hosbra
and you like actually just start conflating the people like the
victims? I I would think you'd like care enough that you wouldn't
just join everything together. You wouldn't just glom it all
together. Unacceptable. That might not represent the interests
of the Palestinians, but that is violent retribution. That was
an inevitability.
So he's saying so him saying that this girl getting paraded around
in Gaza was Right. Right. Right. Right. So I don't know unless
I think unless Shiny was um I don't dude I think unless she was
um unless there's like necroilia happening I don't think she
was she was dead and that's he would know that if he I guess
yeah he's talking someone's talking about Shanny Shanny was dead
although I I remember the Gaza Ministry of Health or something
saying like we took her to a hospital and like when she's been
in the back of that truck you can tell her like neck's broken
like she's dead dead in the back of that truck. Oh what just
happened? So Ellen was the goat of daytime television for a while.
And by the goat, I mean the person. Ain't no way. I just Okay.
Fine. We're fine. But you know, this is not the main goal of
it. It's more so a land mass and what what they can control and
those actions considered immoral by the opposing party. Yes.
Okay. I'm not really sure what you mean to be honest with you.
Powerful stuff. Continue. Yeah. Don't know. Uh so anyway, so
this is the uh these are the kamas terrorists parading around
the coffins of the uh the babies that they murdered uh with their
bare hands actually. Um and another says the IDF says that a
lot in this conversation like he literally just takes what the
IDF says and he's like this is just correct. Oh, who's it verified
by? Literally nobody. Okay. Uh does does Hamas agree? Does Hamas
because listen if both Hamas and the IDF agree we can say that
like that happened, right? Like in death totals, I think Hamas
and Israel don't go that far apart usually, right? In individual
cases, they will, but when you do like total casualty counts,
Israel will go, "Yeah, you guys are raising it up too much."
But they're not going to go down by like 90%. They go down by
like 20%. Right? They don't they don't take like 80% off. It's
it's a lot less. So again, I just want to know what Hamas said
actually happened here. Unironically, just to see if it matches
because maybe they said, "Hey, there's actually these are kids
coffins." Hassan lie by the way is Hassan says that no I don't
believe that Kamas killed them. It was probably like an Israeli
missile strike that killed them but it was it was
say and it's unverified and hey okay I mean I don't I don't necessarily
believe that either I'm sure Hamas says a lot of people died
to Israel. Yeah, exactly. I don't believe either way. I I wouldn't
jump to a conclusion personally without having something verified.
you know, if Israel haven't shared the information, there's not
a statement from someone else saying this is true, then and Hamas
have a conflicting story, I would just personally wait. I wouldn't
take a firm stance. I would say this is what one side says, is
what the other side says and and yeah, hold off on firmly concluded.
But no, no is uh Noox is fully on board with if the IDF says
it. Yeah, exactly. The United Health Organization actually I
did autopsy on the body and the bodies were beaten to death.
The first the first lie about this conflict that I remember him
telling was it was something along the lines of uh there was
a hospital that Yes. Yep. Yep. Yep. A hospital. And then he was
basically saying you you can say it. Yeah, that's fine. There
there was a hospital that was um well, I wouldn't say blown up.
They said it was blown up. It turns out that the explosion mostly
took place in the parking lot, but um they there was a Wait,
how's that hospital? Hold on. That was Al Shifa. Can we find
Can we go to Google Maps? Hold on. Al Shifa Hospital, Gaza. Can
I find Can I find this on maps? And then How's it looking? Let's
go. Let's go to Yeah, let's go to this right here. That shit's
looking good. That shit's looking totally like a structure that
exists. Yo, that's treating patients right now. True. Listen,
maybe it it's entirely possible maybe some of these other structures
are the hospital. Okay. Possibly like this is just the center
or something, but I hope I hope not. All right. I hope it is.
Any anyone got a sick grandma? I'm pretty sure it's got three
beds. Okay. Jesus Christ. All right. Maybe that maybe that's
just the the parking lot or something. Maybe this is actually
El Shifa Hospital here. It is.
There's definitely a lot of rubble around it. Is this
Bro, stop being Stop. Stop. Wait. Clean the business, Jason.
Clean the claim the
Wait, is it offering me that somewhere? Yes. Wait, where is it?
I don't see it. Under under the number. Under the number. Wait.
Oh, business. Yeah, let's go. I don't have to Google my business.
Wait, is it offering me that somewhere? Yes. Wait, where is it?
I don't see it. Under under the number under the number. Wait.
Oh, yeah. Let's go. Have to Google my business for Ali that was
quote unquote blown up. And um you know, Hassan immediately goes
on stream. Israel's doing war. True. Actually, Nux isn't doing
misinformation. Okay, he said they struck the parking lot. It
turns out if you turn the entire hospital into a parking lot.
You're only hitting parking lot at that point. Okay, they're
technically correct. Let's go. For crimes, they're attacking
hospitals. Uh and then it turned out later that um it wasn't
Israel that attacked that hospital. It was uh Hamas. They actually
um their rocket, I think, misfired and blew up their own hospital.
And they blamed it. Did they even say it was an Islamic Jihad
rocket, wasn't it? Or some It was Yeah, it was Pij. It was a
PI rocket. Yeah, it's He's not even getting the story right.
Yeah, it was a It was a PI rocket, apparently. Yeah. Yeah, according
to Not Alifa. No, Alshifa was the one where they hit the They
hit the parking lot and then they I'm almost positive Alshiva
was that one. Oh, maybe it is Ali. You know what, Whiskey Will?
I actually don't remember now. It could be Ali where they where
they hit the hospital. Google Google Maps that one. Google Google
one. You think it you think it's going to go better? Uh why wouldn't
it? Ali Hospital, Gaza. That was that that you are right whoever
said that. Um now here's the only thing about this is I'm going
to get a location for it and I think the location is going to
be because if I remember correctly trying to look up Alali before
actually broke really badly. Like it didn't find it wasn't listed
correctly. Alshifa is the one with the tunnels. Yes. and Ali
I that's what made me remember it's saying here I don't know
if this is correct I literally don't it looks like there's some
stuff around it well it would be this right here medical center
but I think I think Alali is a name that's like comes up multiple
times in Gaza and the Google maps for it is like pretty bad any
Palestinians in chat I recognize the yeah was okay any ls Israel
and Hassan believed it and every single independent organization
that looked into it was like no we we saw the rocket. We saw
how it happened. It was definitely Kamas that did it. And Hassan
to this day has not corrected the record. And still, man, I it's
hard to say for sure what happened. Okay, it seems like the PI
rocket being the thing that blew up there is the most likely
thing, but I do remember Israel released some calls that I think
there was a lot of reason.
Yeah, it was spliced. It was It was blatantly spliced, I'm pretty
sure. Right.
It was spliced.
Yeah. So, I saw like some of the tracking for like the projectile
that likely crashed there from like the one of the geoloccated
accounts and it seems to be compelling, but I do remember for
some reason Israel came out and put just put a bunch of propag
I feel like Israel actually thought they were responsible and
they like put out some some propaganda and then they realized
oh actually we it wasn't us oh safe and they never really got
with for it. Didn't the NYT still stand by the reporting? That
did happen for a little while. It took them a while to change
it. I've seen like lots of different there was a lot of propaganda
going back and forth around it like flick live while it happened
and Alazer broke the news within minutes and the line that declared
Israel definitely did it with the line that okay there was a
refugee camp in the car park of the hospital that got hit if
I recall correctly Israel was also shooting down launch rockets
oh sure but this oh there's like yeah I don't think we can go
back through it I I do remember that like again the geoloccated
account seems to track the the projectile that that disconnects
and like malfunctions
claimed that Israel blew up the hospital. Are you serious? He
just hasn't corrected the record. Not that I know of. Maybe maybe
I He did it and I missed it, but I'm pretty sure he did. Crazy.
Yeah, cuz I remember um I'm pretty sure Willie Mack show covered
this uh in one of his videos and that's how I found out covered
it. It must be true. I'm shocked that he hasn't. Okay, continue.
You should be nicer to Willie Mack and Nicholas. Okay, they're
both uh heroic patriots. They do what this country needs. Yeah.
What country is that? I don't know. But as far as I'm aware,
he didn't uh he didn't. But you'll have to recognize something
else that Hassan likes doing when he likes talking about war
crimes. Um okay, I'll I'll I'll show you this one after. In the
meantime, this is what I was talking about before with uh them
doing a coffin dance with the uh babies that they murdered. This
morning near Han Ununice, a most Macab handover ceremony, Hamas
fighters carry the coffin of four dead Israeli hostages, two
of them children on stage. An offensive propaganda message blaming
P offensive propaganda message. Why are you laughing? Why would
you laugh? Yeah. So, so hold on. One, where's the dancing? I
don't see I don't see actual dancing. Okay. And two, he's laughing
at the propaganda image of Netanyahu.
What? Why? What? Yeah. Why I said the coffin dance thing was
kind of proven. I I meant it's not actually they weren't actually
dancing. There's like something that can be construed as a celebration.
And obviously people probably say it is absolutely a celebration
for deaths and there's going to be another argument on the other
side. But yeah. Okay. But Hassan is definitely just laughing
at the vampire Netanyahu, right? Like that seems to be the clear
thing that he's laughing at that there's like a picture of Netanyahu
with like the vampire. He's like got blood draining from his
fangs onto this family. That's like clearly what he's laughing
at. The war criminal Netanyahu and his Nazi army killed them
with missiles from Zionist warplanes. He is clearly just laughing
at He laughs at the narration.
Offensive propaganda message. Why are you laughing? Why would
you laugh? Okay, but he's laughing at offensive propaganda message.
He doesn't find that offensive. He agrees with it. Anyway, like
doing this whole weird laughing supporting terrorist. I could
show you. I mean, whatever. You got that. Wait, wait, just go
back. People thought it was like an extended laugh, like more
of a scoff. Uh, a cheeto is going to have No, I actually don't
go back and play the clip cuz like I'm not going to like people
laugh at inappropriation, you know, like just just play just
play just play just of four dead Israeli. I want to see what
he says to it matters more. I'm not going to stage him for a
offensive propaganda message blaming offensive propaganda message.
Why are you laughing? Why would you laugh? Whatever. This clip
doesn't have Is it just Ethan? Honestly, I mean I mean I guess
if he clip doesn't have it if he defends it. I can tell you what
he says. I can tell you what he says after that. Oh well, you
know if you say it if you say it is I found the Ali hospital
four weeks later. Uh is really Oh, they they did go into it.
I It's fine. Offensive propaganda message. Uh literally this
is Israel. You they can't even say propaganda. They can't even
say propaganda when they're being killed. Like that's that's
like the rest of his his argument. Oh, essentially. Yeah. I don't
understand. Ali is not doing well. Hold on. They struck this
hospital. This is Ali.
Oh, cool. Oh, well, at least we know it wasn't Israeli strike
the first time. Double tap. Always double tap. Okay. You got
to make sure you double tap to get your targets. So, over here
behind So, you see here the terrorists, here the coffins, the
people they murdered. Gotcha. Um, behind them they have a picture
of the Israeli prime minister uh Netanyahu like photoshopped
to look like a vampire and uh the war criminal Netanyahu and
his Nazi army. That is that is not funny. Hold on. I've got a
clip for this. Hold on. Where is it? Where is it? I need to find
this clip really quickly. We're going to wait. Dude, this is
this is so inappropriate. It's actually so disgusting. I need
to find a clip that actually correctly conveys just how upsetting
this is. Okay, I'm not going to be able to find it. Elf dreamer.
Dude, I'm not going to be able to find it. I'm so annoyed. Dude,
why does Windows Search sucks so badly? Can somebody explain
that to me? It's actually the worst ever. It's like not indexed
in any way. You can never find anything with Windows Search.
It's so stupid. Army killed them with missiles from Zionist warplanes.
Talking about how uh he they're claiming that Netanyahu and Israel
killed these hostages, which is not true. Um, they killed they
killed them themselves. I actually lied. Okay, Hassan, you can't
do this. Hassan, this is so inappropriate. Okay, Hassan, this
is not funny. Oh, no. I mean, no.
Do not laugh, oh
no. Oh,
no. No.
No. That's terrible. Oh, you hate to see it. Oh, boohoo.
Boo. I hate to see that. Oh man, you hate that's him laughing
at Sneo getting banned like two years ago or something. I don't
know. I remember that. Like I remember I remember this one. So
[__] funny. Um, so this is uh So he laughs and he's
like offensive propaganda message. What do you mean? They're
at war. They're allowed to propaganda. They claim that their
enemy murdered their own people when
Yeah. So he's he's just defending misinformation. Okay. Not even
necessarily true. Uh, possibly. But he's laughing at like I feel
like he's literally just laughing at calling Netanyahu like a
bloodthirsty war criminal is not offensive propaganda. That's
just the truth. Yeah, that's and I, by the way, I just point
out if you're on this, if you if you take sides on this based
on what Ethan Klein thinks, why is Hold on. Actually, isn't this
the biggest indication that Ethan Klein's a shill? Where does
Ethan Klein disagree? Why do you disagree? Why is the problem
here? I thought I thought he totally hated Netanyahu's a war
criminal. Evil war criminal. I don't understand. This is like
this clip's just a straight up condemnation of Ethan saying he
thinks this is genocide and that Netanyahu is a war criminal.
Oh, it's almost like he doesn't actually, you know, really give
a or even think about that sort of thing and only cares about
his personal grievances with the people. Yeah, we're all supposed
to care that the other side is saying you for only caring about
the personal grievances over the politics. Um, right. Okay, cool.
Interesting. Well, his focus is on the dead. No, I mean, your
focus should be on what the actual clip is about. what Hassad's
laughing at. What he literally says, what he's laughing at. Yeah,
I Okay, I kind of see that. I mean, I think the laughing part
is like um I don't know what you said about it, but I mean like
ultimately like I'm I'm going to laugh at some up like if I laugh
at like the Shiloh Hendricks clip where she called the kid the
it's like well I don't support her saying the I just think that
it's like so like it's like you know people laugh in awkward
situations to diffuse the awkwardness or just because they feel
uncomfortable saying the is he a race traitor? What is going
on? Dude, that's the roughest part. I was like, "Dude, I'm not
even like I'm not even like, no, not a race war." I'm just like,
"Dude, I'm not I'm not racewaring over a lady who says the Okay,
find a better champion." All right, find a better champion. I'm
not going for find a different fight. Okay. Yeah. This is what
happened to black people, okay? They picked They picked the guy
with the fentanyl in the system. Okay. They didn't pick the right
guy. We We need the perfect victim. People say there is no perfect
victim. We need the perfect one. Okay. That's what we need. I
don't know. I don't know if you said that. you know, always laughing.
I mean, when Ethan Grant stands over laughing, I'm not I'm not
going to like, you know, I think that's silly. But I think that's
valid. I think that's valid for sure. But I would argue, but
no, I mean, ultimately like what you just said is true. If he's
defending misinformation, it's stupid. Laughing over someone
saying the answer and uh laughing at the misinformation and defending
the misinformation of people that murdered and are parading in
the streets with blasting music with the coffins of babies. I
think that's a slightly different like obviously. Yeah. I mean,
to be to be fair, I think I mean, this I don't want to get too
autistic with this. I It's not even worth I'll make this very
clear. I I also think there is a difference between like laughing
and then like a chuckle in between like the sentence. And I think
it's a chuckle. And I think Ethan's like he's laughing. I don't
know. I think it's not the laughing. It's not the laughing as
much as the uh the defense. Yeah, I think the defense is worse.
Yeah, I agree. It's the the wholesome coverage. What he portrayed
as he's like he was laughing at them dancing.
Yeah, for real. It was just a completely madeup explanation of
what happened here. 100%. Yeah, totally. I think Yeah, he watched
this and he didn't once say like, "Wow, that's really up that
they murdered these people." And these like you can't see them.
These little white things over here in the coffins, these are
pictures of the people that were supposedly in the coffins, right?
Um I say supposedly because they returned one of the wrong bodies
when this happened. Oh yeah, they didn't return the mother's
body either. They they returned the wrong body or something.
Jesus. Okay. Pretty pretty [__] up. Okay. So yeah,
I mean honestly those people wait was it was it a Palestinian
person that they returned the body of? I think they Yeah. Yeah,
it was worse. Also, yeah, I don't know why Twitter's doing this
now. I thought that was a bug on my my screen. It's like the
video is different now. But um anyway, yeah, I think the defense
of this is like worse because it's like you know whether you
laugh or whether you defend it's like you you can have like an
awkward laugh and say this is like unacceptable and then I think
that's actually um you know it goes it goes way further than
uh you know could you imagine if Assan had shooters to go find
clips like that and like he just had people showing him like
where Ethan had been inconsistent and he had like any at all
the the the Okay, reach out laugh plus defense if that makes
sense. Yeah, for one very simple and quick $50,000 donation to
Pixies, go and go. Okay. No. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. 50k
and a visa. Excuse me. Oh, okay. 50k and a visa. I don't think
the laughing is the problem. Yeah. 100%. I think the problem
is more defending the terrorists that are murdering. The laughing
was the problem until it's like challenged and then now the laughing
isn't the problem because I guess you push back at all, dude.
children. Okay. Kind of thing, right? And so, so going on from
that, right, what else has he said about the war? What I was
gonna say, what I was going to say um in regards to the uh the
hospital thing. So, his argument very often is that why is um
why is uh Israel bombing hospitals and stuff like that? and um
kamas the terrorists they um they put their rocket launchers
in hospitals and in playgrounds
um to shoot at Israel. So when Israel attacks the rocket launcher
which is placed in a hospital they are also attacking a hospital.
Uh Hamas uses human shields and like completely verified completely
verified that they use human shields and uh by every different
society on the planet the UN discovered this as dude I uh I feel
like I feel like Naku could turn me actually anti-semitic. Like
if you started like I literally I fully believe the exact narrative
that's on the book about the Holocaust, but if Nux like started
trying to convince me it happened, I'm very scared of what would
happen to me. Okay. It would be a terrifying day for me. All
right. Wait, have you gone to the concentration camp bit? No.
Oh god, dude. Did I just say something prophetic accidentally?
Yeah, a little bit. Yeah. Although I think we I we probably saw
it. I We aren't that far away now, I assume, from where we actually
started watching. Yeah, I mean, we were talking around in Discord.
So, uh, so when you say that Israel attacked a hospital and it's
a war crime, um, and it turns out it wasn't even Israel that
attacked that hospital. It was Gaza that blew up their own hospital
and they actually do put their rocket launchers in hospital.
Wait, why is this guy conflating Gazins and Hamas or Gazins and
PI? I thought I thought they protested. I thought they weren't
the same group. I thought these were like violent authoritarian
these families and like leaving them the family members. Knox
is the IDF and Lood means he's responsible for them. That's pretty
awesome, I guess. So, well, I don't I don't agree with that,
but you know, like he's arguing for these things. Wild wild misinformation
to just say look at what's going on here. Do Do you think that
two things can be true at once where it's like I'm not here defending
everything Israel has ever done. Yeah. Okay. I want Israel. Of
course.
At the start of the six day war, five countries attacked Israel
out of nowhere and Israel had to heroically fight them off. definitely
made some uh some pretty awful decisions in regards to what they've
done for sure. But Ri just said Riy just said a Cheeto is like
hopefully not 100 I feel like Queen Bee is just sitting in chat
telling him what to say to not be or somebody is I feel like
somebody's saying like I feel like he's mostly reading chat to
get these responses. I don't know what I'm I'm in chat later,
right? Yeah, I know. In every single instance. Okay, that's kind
of what I was trying to get at is because I mean from what I
understand and the the content that I've seen around the war,
I mean it does seem like there has been um decisions made by
the Israeli government and the Israeli military that have been
like extremely up. And I'm not saying that it's like I mean look
like it's it's a war, right? So obviously there's going to be
uh like um you have to like I I don't know I mean international
law is kind of fake. So if you violate it during a war, it's
like well you did that. It's a war crime. It's like well war
itself is a you know it's like American thing. And so you know
when Israel does things that people think are like inexcusable
and stuff like that. Um I would say like you know isn't this
all inexcusable? Like isn't like Israel is doing you know what
I hadn't thought about? I hadn't thought about the idea that
maybe sides might be some bad people on both sides. I think war
just sucks man. Inexcusable. Palestine is doing inexcusable.
I mean, it's a war. I don't know. Maybe that's just like a enlightened
centrist like damn like, you know, but this is worse.
I love that he says that. He says that as if like he knows it's
not that. Maybe this is just but it's like no that is entirely
that is literally what you're doing right now. I mean, I would
I would argue it's a a little bit of an enlightened centrist
moment, but uh whatever. I I mean I mean I don't No, I mean I
mean please critique me because I I don't I mean I'm not like
a political I think I think Israel definitely I think Israel
uh definitely did some uh not valid things for sure. Uh absolutely.
I think they they overdid it in specific instances for real.
For real. Oh 100%. Yeah. Like for example for real for real guys
for real for real. Well this is um this is a a terrorist tunnel.
Like there are 300 miles of terrorist tunnels in Gaza. 300 miles.
Um and um the reason I mention this is because they don't open
the bomb shelters and tunnels to civilians in Gaza. They don't
do that because they want Okay. Again, they're terrorists. The
Hamas terrorists want civilian casualties so that on the world
stage they could say, "Look how bad Israel is." Mhm. It's like
you have to realize they want the civilian casualties. And that's
like so this is the terrorist tunnel that they don't let civilian
here in Baha in Gaza 699 battalion. We see here a fighting tunnel
of Hamas 15 m deep right outside a school. Right. So like if
you're going to have these tunnels over here that the terrorists
use to store ammunition and capture hostages and move and operate
and they they put them on purpose right next to schools and right
next to hospitals. So, it's a really like it's a terrible war.
It's a terrible war, right? Here's another another one. What
do you think about like people that are saying like Israel's
doing genocide? Cuz I see that like all the time. Like that's
what Assan says, Noah Samson says. I mean, unfortunately, Israel's
kind of Israel kind of slowplayed it. Now, I feel like they're
starting to become a little bit more a little bit more of like
an argument for it. I don't think there was an argument before
before this like operation. I don't think there's an argument
for it. Now after this operation it's like bro this I defended
you guys. This is this is about why we started watching as well
I think. Right. Um and it's like what what do you think about
that? So obviously the debate is very contested. Do you know
the definition of genocide? Uh I mean I think the definition
is genocide is kind of used for everything right now. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Like like I think genocide is like it became one of those
buzzwords like uh if guys we need to get you know like like eight
subs. No, no, no, no, no. Six subs. Six subs, guys. We need six
subs. Okay, give me six subs and we can make it through the end
of this debate. Okay, six subs. I love you guys. This uh I think
40 bucks. No, 30 bucks. 30 bucks. Okay. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. Okay. Kick subs, Twitch primers, anything. Anything
you guys got, throw it down. Yeah. Yeah. It's like to erase a
certain Do we want to? I don't know if you want to. Yeah. So,
I mean, I'll be real. I'm probably not going to stop streaming
this in any case. So, if you don't pay, I'm probably just going
to go until the end of this anyway, but I would appreciate it
since, you know, I'm going to do the content. I mean, I think
that they kind of are, though, aren't they just trying to like
erase Palestinians?
Uh, Stalin is sloth with a five gifted right off the bat. Starting
strong. Thank you very much, Stalin Sloth. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. And Admiral Monkey with one gifted. That's six right
away. Oh my god, we didn't have to shield that long. Thank you
guys. Okay, sorry. I'll go back. I think that they kind of are
though. Aren't they just trying to like erase Palestinians? Well,
not in Gaza. They would have bombed Gaza a lot more. Okay. I
mean, Gaza has 2.1 million people. Listen, Gaza is way Gaza is
like way too strong. Going way too strong. Okay. There's there's
like at least 20% of the structures left. You cannot say we're
trying to genocide anybody. Is that before the war? I don't know.
I made up that number off the top of my head. I thought it was
like 5% to be honest. I thought I heard like 95% of structures
were gone, but sure. I think 95 is probably high based off some
of the map things. Although if you depends on what you want to
say, 95% of structures damaged or like partially destroyed, I'd
say. Oh yeah, it might be. It might be damaged. Yeah. Yeah, it
might include damage. Yeah, that's true. Yeah. Yeah. True. True.
True. But there are some some ones that are standing it, but
it's like okay, if it's standing with a giant hole like one of
the walls was crumbled, I don't know how much that means, right?
If the matter is not disintegrated, it it counts. Okay. It counts.
It counts. It's still building and they still have 2.1 million
people right now, right? in I mean we were technically trying
to like genocide the Japanese during World War II, right? Absolutely
not. What are you talking about? That's not true. You don't think
so? What are you that does he again? This is the opposite. You
remember that Destiny hypothetical where he's like even if they
nuke Gaza wouldn't necessarily be a genocide. A Cheeto's like
taken the opposite side. Nuclear bomb means automatic genocide.
You are genociding anybody you've launched a nuke against. Little
crazy. No, for sure not. Definitely not. They they tried to end
the war. Some people would argue that dropping two nuclear bombs
on Japan was incredibly excessive. For sure, that's kind of that's
kind of where I'm going, right? They weren't trying to every
Japanese person. Okay. No, definitely not. I mean, you could
argue that it was definitely excessive. That's I mean, that's
kind of where I'm going with it is it's like I don't know if
you drop two nuclear bombs on a on a on a group of people and
don't want them. I mean I mean I guess I suppose like when I
don't know. I don't know. I mean, I guess it wasn't a strategic
attempt to erase the Japanese people, so it probably wasn't,
but the intent is required for genocide. That's a good point.
The intent. So, so Hitler against the Jews, that was a genocide.
And listen, bro, I'm not I'm not arguing from this specific point.
I'm not going to argue from any point of like, in fact, in fact,
Hamas terrorists. Well, hold on, hold on. People are going to
eat me alive in the comments. People are going to eat me. God.
Oh, god. In the comments for the Stop talking about Hitler. Stop
talking about Hitler, please. For the love of God, make it like
clear. Like, I'm not like this is all like I'm I'm like workshopping
this in my brain as we speak, okay? I'm not saying No, he's not.
He checked with the war stuff, I am here learning from someone
who has done way more research than me. Okay? So, before people
want to call me names in the comments, I'm learning. I'm making
Yeah, I made one report. If I say, "Isn't that like blank?" and
you don't like the simile there, it's like because I'm, you know,
I'm working out of my brain. Okay, continue. I have to save face
a little bit. Fair. Fair. Yeah. So, um, genocide is the intent
to wipe out an entire
uh, this guy is terrified. There's I'm surprised that he's letting
somebody, you know, coach him on loving Israel right now, considering
that like a Jew haunts his nightmares way like day and night.
Okay, this guy's like terrified of Aiden right now, which is
crazy to me. Aiden's like such a sweetheart. He's absolutely
terrified. People, uh, and if the intent is not there, it's not
a genocide. Um, and uh, in fact, if the intent is there and uh,
and you're not successful, it's still a genocidal fight. For
example, the Hamas terrorists that say they want to all Jews,
um, they say they want to all Jews. They they say this in their
charter, by the way, their charter is um, let there be no tree
that doesn't scream there is a Jew behind this tree. Come kill
the Jew behind this tree. That is their charter. That is the
hadith that's getting quoted there.
Um trying to think. Okay, hold on. I'm like trying to think.
So from here I think we are definitely watching at this point.
I remember the hadith getting quoted. They want to kill all Jews.
That's what they say they want to do. They are genocidal. So
Hassan supporting Hamas makes him pro genocide. Uhhuh. Cuz they
are genocidal. The terrorists are genocidal. Um now whatever
you want to say, I know that it's a it's a currently contested
debate. I'm no political geopolitical historian, but I think
if you're being realistic about it, um I don't think there's
a genocide in Gaza. Okay. Interesting. But obviously I am I am
biased and uh because you know I I had a family member that was
murdered October 7th by Hamas. Are you serious? So I Yep. Jesus
Christ. So I'm obviously biased. However, and and I recognize
No, I mean I mean like I can't I don't like that totally anonymous
VTuber is able to invoke the emotional weight of that without
anyone being able to check. I I don't like that. I'm a sn cool
guy. I'm crying for him right now. I don't know. I just I don't
think that matters. Yeah, I don't think you say it literally
doesn't matter. I Yeah, you should say it doesn't matter as well.
I don't think you should invoke that emotional weight in the
debate like it especially if no one can even check if it's true.
Like crazy. That that would be very funny for him to say that
I had a member a family member die to Hamas like and and make
a point.
It's one of those like thing negative that's not I'm biased but
my family member died to this horrible group man like valid as
like Jesus Christ I'm I'm actually really sorry I didn't know
that. I'm so sorry. Yeah. Um it it is indeed very for sure and
uh I'm recognizing that I am by but I am also being realistic
for a second and saying if you look at the population of Gaza
in 2022 there were 2.1 million people. If you look at the population
in Gaza right now there's 2.1 million people. That's not a genocide.
You got to realize Israel has nuclear weapons. Israel could wipe
out Gaza in one. Obviously they're not doing that. I mean like
if they did that like that would be like a world war the most.
Oh I mean no I don't think so. I do wonder what would happen
though. I don't think you could possibly get pulled into a world
war that just even for the access of resistance or whatever and
not pass path the there's like another name the axis of resistance
is is Iran and its um proxies right? What is the there's like
a it's not it's not the axis of e they don't call it the axis
of evil. What do they call Iran, Russia, China? Because I thought
that was the name for like another group that the US qualifies
together as like America's sort of like uh enemies or something.
They called the Axis of something. I thought it's not bricks.
No, it would be a world blowout. But yeah, I don't think China
and Russia are going to go and join a major conflict there. It
could turn into uh it could turn into like Iran fighting Israel
like out outright. I thought the axis of resistance hold on.
I thought the axis of resistance was explicitly Iran and its
allies, but maybe not. Maybe it is China and Russia as well.
Formal coalition of Iran, Iranian supported militant and political
organizations across the Middle East. I was correct. You guys
moment you use nuclear weapons, you're Yes. The That would be
like a world war. The moment you use nuclear weapons, you're
Yes. The moment that I'm sure of that I'm No, hold on. Stop.
Stop. Maybe not. He saw he saw that uh what do you call it? He
saw that really really old YouTube video where all the countries
shoot nukes at each other. Yeah. For real? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
No, that's what everyone thinks about with the little dots going
from each country, dude. Yeah. That's all they think. That's
all they see in their head when they talk about this. That's
actually nuke. Everybody shoots. That's so real.
Yeah. That's Yeah. End of the world. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
That's the video. It's not But it's like, dude, I I think there's
been like papers on this from most mil from not most from like
respected military strategists where it's like, "Hey, you could
actually use nukes right now. I don't think anybody would freak
out that badly." And then everybody's like, "Shut the [__]
up. Shut the [__] up. Shut the [__] up."
But more um small tactical nukes, not um not like mega nukes,
not like hydrogen bombs. Hold on. Hold on. Let me just say this.
Let me say this. The moment you invite nuclear war, uh it might
have been axis of upheaval. That's when the whole world gets
involved. Yeah. That's generally when there are two different
countries that both have nuclear. This is like again I'm not
uh Israel's air force could wipe out Gaza in a day essentially
well with the amount of like weapons that they forget forget
nukes forget nukes okay sure continue but they could they absolutely
could now obviously I hope that they don't do that would be awful
but um and uh but isn't well you don't believe that you don't
believe he loves uh all fellow humans I'm just I'm very convinced
right now frankly thanks for the thanks for the image, but trust
me if I pull that up, it's just it's a very cringe video. I've
watched it like at some point in the past 5 years is not it's
like uh it's a very cringe video actually now. Well, well, isn't
that like a It's better in your memories than it actually is
in execution. Trust me, like a bad argument because that like
that's saying like like we could kind of erase any country we
want, right? And like that's just saying like well because we're
doing it over the span of like however long and we're not blowing
them up immediately, then we're not doing a genocide. Like that's
a bad argument. Well, is anyone accusing America of doing genocide
because America could
No, but you're you're you're saying that like, you know, if there
is a genocide, we could have already done it. Well, Israel is
being accused of doing a genocide. Right. And the argu we wanted
to genocide these guys, we'd be genociding them. Okay. The the
proof is in the pudding. We are not killing all of these people.
That's proof that we don't want to kill them. Okay. Argument
is the genocide is wiping out. Well, I mean, or you're just playing
a political game. I don't know. Entire I don't know. People.
Yeah. Right. Just because we have the proof of non- genocide
is we have enough munitions to like totally kill a bunch of people
and we don't do that like indiscriminately right now. That proved
that we don't want we don't wish harm on these people. Israel
has the power to wipe out the entire people and is not doing
that. In fact, if you look at the military, if you look at the
militant to civilian casualty chart, it's on par with any American
attack anywhere in the Middle East over the last 20 years. Okay.
Well, I don't that's apples to oranges. No, no, it that Oh my
god, he actually got the argument correct. I don't think he knows
what he means or I don't think he knows the actual argument,
but yes, it is apples to oranges. It's not because it's not going
out there there. I mean, okay, there was technically an American
occupation in Iraq, right? But I don't believe the occupation
was quite as uh I don't think it was quite as brutal. It's probably
quite brutal at the start. I don't know, but it's not the long-term
like multi-deade long occupation, right? They're specifically
targeting civilians different like I don't know if you know this,
but uh Israel has a um a thing where they drop leaflets on buildings
saying that we will be bombing this building in an hour. We found
out that there are terrorist infrastructure in this building.
We will be bombing this building in the hour. What is a leaf?
What is a leaflet? Leaflet like little papers. Like they'll fly
over it. They'll drop like a ton of little papers over a building.
The papers will be saying we will be bombing this building. Get
out of there. People will flee the building. And then they'll
blow up the building. Okay. Like that's that's not genocidal.
I mean, would genocidal people really roof knock? Okay. He's
about to say roof. Hello. I was about to go down. Say roofing.
Okay. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Continue. I mean I mean I guess that
that part That That makes sense. No, he's going to say door knockings.
They want to vote.
True. We got DG out in Gaza door knocking right now. Oh my god.
400,000 voter contacts. Let's go. Worst hacker you've ever seen.
And it is just straight up like so crazy. Uh it is funny. It's
very funny. Um I guess just like what you're saying is that just
because they have the capacity to to erase this country with
nuclear weapons and they haven't, then therefore they're not
genocidal. I I don't like that argument. I'm not like I'm not
saying they are I'm saying that argument is bad. I personally
don't agree because I think genocide is an incredibly like harsh
claim. Uhhuh. Like Hitler did anything in his power to kill Jews.
Like that dude was a Jew machine. I don't think that's true.
Wait, wait, wait, hold on. It's going exact way you said it would.
It's going exact way. Whatever Jay talks about Jason said earlier,
if Nox tried to come in through the Holocaust happened, I'd probably
doubt it. And that way, oh yeah, Hill was a
That wasn't the part I was doubting. I said I don't think he
did everything in his power. I think they diverted away from
the war too much. But I I'm saying they could have completely
diverted away from the war and made sure they could have like
bombed those camps. They could have made sure nobody gets out
of those camps, right? I think there are probably things they
could have done. Uh, sure, egregious Phil, but it's like, yeah,
like honestly, okay, this is I think is an irritable monster,
personally. We'll we'll get to this. I love I love how terrible
things to black people. I actually love so much right now, bro.
Yeah. No, I agree with you entirely. Uh you're going to you're
going to ruin it later when we do the line. Okay. Uh all I'm
saying is obviously they're they could have done more. They they
could have done more. It's them not maximizing their potential
to the maximum number of Jews does not mean they weren't genocidal.
That's actually the exact opposite. They were genocidal. They
were doing it in a way that was like uh what do you call it?
Like consistent with them still trying to maintain a war machine.
Anyway, all right, bro. Got six million people. Like, you don't
realize there are less Jews in the world right now than there
were 1938. How is that possible? Because they Okay, dude. Wait,
how is that possible? What happened after 1938? I don't know.
There were 16 million Jews in 1938. 6 million were killed. And
right now there were there are 15 million Jews. There's $16 million.
50 million. Is that true, Chad? Chad, that's crazy. Chad, looked
that up. Chad, is that true, chat? World Jew population. What?
What? Or maybe maybe there were more. Maybe. No, do not link
me to Madagascar plan. Stop. There's 15.8 million Jewish people
in the world. Wait. And there were over 16 million in 1938. So,
the Jews have still not fully recovered um and may never recover.
But that's not the point. The point I'm trying to make is that
that's genocidal. Is a Cheeto Canadian. I don't think so. I pray
not. Okay. A Cheeto nationality born in the Thank God. Thank
Thank Holy [__] Wait, hold on. Sorry. I just asked
Chat GBT. I'm going to keep it a buck with you. I still have
the posit going on here. Hold on. Hold on. Wait. Hold on. Wait.
Hold on. Sorry. I just asked Chat GBT. I'm going to keep it a
buck with you. It says there are more Jews now than in 1938.
Estimates about Oh [__] Oh sh Chat GPT coming down
on N. 16. In 1938 there was about 16.6 6 million Jews worldwide.
In 2024, there was 15.7 million Jews worldwide. Oh, man. Can
Can he not do math or can chat GPT not do math? Still fewer than
Yeah, I know. I know. I know. But it's not. I know. I know. I
know. I know. I know. I know. It's not done. It's not done. It
says still fewer than pre-Holocaust numbers, but steadily recovering.
However, if you meant currently in 2025, then the number has
likely surpassed or is about to surpass preholocaust numbers.
So, I guess you're I mean, I guess you're close enough. Oh, I
guess you're close enough. But um you got the point. The point
that I was trying to make. Okay. Okay, JTock, calm down. Do not
make a joke about that number rising and the increasing anti-semitism
in the world. Okay, we can't make that joke. That joke would
be [__] up.
Okay, these things are unrelated actually. Uh they're not. Why
you asking Chad GBT? That's what that CDN Chronics got super
mad about. I I wonder what would happen if you I wonder how much
someone a hypothetical person of course who doesn't exist and
wouldn't do this because this would be a terrible thing to do
but I wonder how much a hypothetical person would get making
a joke that basically says you know Ethan Klein's lashing out
so bad inciting so much anti-semitism and then maybe led it on
to make a joke that refers back to a joke Ethan Klein made about
Ben Shapiro. Like, how much would that person get, do you think,
if they made the same joke Ethan Klein made about Ethan Klein
about Ben Shapiro about Ethan Klein? Uh, I hope you didn't do
that. I haven't done that. I I wouldn't do that because it's
a disgusting thing that I would disavow if anyone did that. I
would never do that. I'm ask I'm theorizing like if you made
that joke that Ethan made about Ben Shapiro about Ethan, how
crazy would would people go over that, do you think? Um, if Hassan
did that, uh, it would be over. If depends on who did it. Okay.
Well, it would it could it'd have to be another Jew at least
because that affects public perception a lot. So, that's like
a controlling factor, right? So, it' have to be let's say Sam
Ceda made a joke along those lines. Oh, I don't know. I think
uh yeah, I have no idea. Be pretty. Is it even that up? It would
it even be that up if it's another Jewish person saying it? I
have no idea. I feel like it would it would everyone would be
freaking out. Dan would be tweeting about it non-stop or do you
think it would get shielded because Ethan had done it before?
Do you think maybe they just would be completely confused on
it? No, I think they'd say it's a different time that anti-semitism
is on the rise. You can't do it now. Oh my god. Don't you know
anti-semitism is on the rise? Have you not heard this on the
You could totally get away with it. Quan, thanks for advice,
man. I had to reconnect my headphones really quickly. How Who
else am I supposed to act the like the US? Wait, hold on. Did
we finish? I don't even know if we finished that. Hypothetically,
I don't think you I don't think you should try it. Okay. I I
I would never try it. I said that. That's a disgusting thing.
Yeah. When you say it like that though, I know you would try
it. So, I'm saying don't. Well, so I can just never convince
you that I wouldn't say this. No, that's kind of dope. Okay.
What do you think should be done with the Cheeto and Nukaku equipment?
Census like I'm confused. Don't let them get to you. It's based
chat GBT is based. I just It does the It was quick. It was quick.
All right. Sorry. Okay. Continue. Anyway, we're talking about
genocide. We're talking about genocide, right? Yeah. I think
that argument is bad. I think that argument is bad. That's fine.
Uh I think genocide is the intent, well, the definition of genocide
is the intent to wipe out an um by the fact that you see Israel
is doing everything in their power to not wipe out an entire
people. I would argue that that means that they are not doing
a genocide. Right. Well, I think what you're saying is their
intent is not that because if it was, they would have done it
already. That's like saying, "Oh, I'm not bullying that kid because
if I really wanted to bully him, I would have beat him up already."
It's like, you know, it doesn't really make sense. The intent
makes it the crime. Oh, true. That that is genocide. Yeah. Yeah,
we we did we did talk about that. Yeah. Um well, I don't know
if I guess we I mean, and by the fact, how do we just the hypothetical
here is could the Germans not technically have um like just shot
whatever Jewish person they were taking on those trains to Awitz?
Just shot them and like throw them in. The the point is that
like uh it's the fact that they could but haven't is like a piece
of circumstantial evidence or like a a point you can make, but
it's like no in no way could that ever be deciding. Like obviously
there's more things that going to be at play at any given point
in a country than um just the genocide that's happening. They're
probably going to have uh things that that stretch them and limit
their capacity to genocide or or uh not even limit their capacity
but make it unappealing in some way to go the full way on on
the genocide. I think that's the biggest one, right? I guess
how do we how do we know because yeah, like you said, if it's
a political game being played, if there's benefits that they
see from limiting it or uh things that they might trigger if
they go too go too fast, then yeah, those are going to be factors
that play into it. the crime could still be happening, but um
but it's just not it's not advantageous to do the full thing
right now. If there was no downside to them nuking Gaza and they
still didn't do it, then I would argue that that's Yeah, exactly.
There was literally no limiting balancing factors. You could
say this, but no, the fact obviously there always is. Yeah. Yeah.
Yep. Oh, the intent. Well, the in I think the in You're right.
You can never know intent. Intent is proven by actions. And the
actions are A, not leveling the entire Gaza. B, dropping leaflets
and pamphlets and knocking on doors, telling them in advance
before they bomb their He actually thinks they knock on doors.
Like maybe maybe that is a thing, knocking on, but like I'm almost
positive he means roof knocking right now. Yeah. Like there's
just no way that roof knocking is literally a part of like the
the talking points for this precisely. He I'm almost positive
he means roof. They're buildings. Uh see basically uh essentially
you may not know this, Israel is supplying Gaza right now with
humanitarian aid. Uhhuh. Like if it was a genocide, would Israel
be powering their electricity and sending in food and water?
I I that does not I don't Isn't that true? It's not. First of
all, he says that's aid. They literally control the infrastructure
for water and occupied that area for 20 years now. Yes. It's
like totally insane to first call that aid and then he's saying
basically, well, it's a war, so you shouldn't expect them to
allow them to have electricity and water and food. It's like,
no, just cuz you're at war doesn't mean you get to completely
deprive the civilians of food and food and water. That that's
not how that works. That is that's a war crime. Yeah. And it's
just it's also just not a good argument. Again, um I hate to
point this out. I hate to say this because it it really seems
like I'm making all of the uh I'm making all of the scary optical
arguments tonight, but I'm pretty sure the Germans supplied food
and water and electricity to Awitz. Okay, I'm just I'm just saying
I think that's a thing that happened. Okay. Okay. Cuz no has
got great arguer concentration caps coming up that will fit in
perfectly with that. So that doesn't even seem I'm sorry that
sounds insane. That sounds insane. What am I looking What am
I looking at?
Israel providing Gaza with their electricity, food, and water.
Okay. Who the else would have provided it? That's the point.
Yeah. No, no, no. Hold on, hold on, hold on. Oh, okay. I got
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We were going too soon. That guy's Okay. Is
Israel providing Gaza with
electricity, food, and water? I mean, I shouldn't laugh at him
for typing things in. Like, I I was just googling stuff earlier
when I don't know it, so I shouldn't laugh at him for doing that.
And you know, Chat GBT is probably going to give you like this
whole long answer. I'll I'll just read it. Um, I mean, go for
it. I I you know, look, I I'm just trying to be fair, right?
I I don't want to just like sit here and like, you know, take
everything you say as fact. You know, obviously, you know, you're
a friend and I respect what you have to say, but you know, for
the sake of Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Okay. Um, Israel, I'm biased.
Ooh. I got bad news for you, bro. Go for it. As of May 2025,
Israel is not consistently providing electricity, food, and water
to go to Gaza. Did you see Did you hear the word consistently?
That is true. What does consistently mean? Okay. All right. All
right. Hey, I know what the word consistently. The way that works.
I I love the way that like what a cheeto said doesn't really
disprove anything Nux said and then NX's response isn't really
dealing with like what a like they literally are just it's like
misses on both sides like repeatedly just nobody is Am I consistently
uploading videos? I am. But if I wasn't then I'd still be a YouTuber.
True. True point. Okay. Okay. Let's see what this says. Israel
has cut off electricity supplies to Gaza since October 2023.
Water the block at war. You have to realize there's a war also.
That means Israel does it as a punitive measure. Uh, you could
argue that. You could argue like, oh, we shut off electricity
selectively to like do operations or some. There's a lot of arguments
that they could probably try to make. Right. I do believe at
the start of the war it was shut off. And I do believe that was
mostly as a punitive measure. So,
yeah. During a war, right? Right. During a war, they are still
supplying them and cutting it off strategically for different
operations. Uhhuh. Um, okay. So, well, I'm just going to read
the rest of it. The block. Okay. The blockade has also disrupted
water supplies. The shutdown of
desolination products. I guess that's just like water related
stuff due to power. Yeah. Pull water out of the the Mediterranean
Sea has uh led to critical shortage of of portable water. Doctors
without borders reported that water is being used as a weapon
of war in Gaza, exacerbating the humanitarian crisis. So low
key, bro, they're not supplying electricity or water and food.
They are. So low key they the idea low key low key the idea of
supplying food and water to the enemy in a war is a little bit
wild and yeah but you said that they were doing that. That's
why I said I don't believe you. They were that's not wild. They
control their utilities like and have done for like decades like
like basically there's been a ter there's been like a terrorist
presence in like Hamas shooting rockets at them for like 20 years.
It's been this thing. You've not let them because you needed
to manage this and have an occupation to keep yourselves safe.
You took over like their utilities. Unfortunately, even if that
terrorist presence lands a pretty solid strike on you guys, which
sucks and it's entirely unjustified to kill civilians and whatever,
you don't get to shut off the utilities for the civilians. You
put them in that situation. You still have to maintain that.
It's like a thing that's outside of the rules of engagement or
should be
when when during the war. Yes. It said since 20 October 2020.
I'd say even more than the electricity, the water is like the
big thing because it's literally a desert. Like you have to it's
a desert on a sea. Okay. They need water. Or did it say starve
and and I know dehydrate. I guess these people that's insanely
fed up obviously on your chat GBT. No, it's saying it's saying
since October 2023 or Oh, wait. Oh. Oh, they were doing it. Yes.
Okay. Okay. Okay. I got you. point after
Okay. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. In March 2025, they stopped giving Oh,
okay. All right. So, in March 2025,
um, which by the way is already about how many months into the
war? A year and a half into the war. I just got a YouTube video.
Conun May 3rd, 2025. Is this desperate families scramble for
food cross in battle territory?
Is this like rice, oats? Damn. It's not even I don't even know
if it's rice or oats. kind of just looks
gr It's Zog slop. Finally, we found Zog slop. It's soup. Okay.
All I know is these these kids unironically what Oliver Twist
was getting. Okay. It's I I call it grl. You could call it soup.
I call it grrul. Okay. Grl means a different thing to me. Oh,
I Oh, sure. You're a aren't you? Gross. Gross. Why would you
say that? That like a twist was like white. Listen, white, brown,
we're all going to somebody, okay? That's when they started strategically
turning off power and um you know, stuff like that, right? And
also, you should recognize Hamas turned water pipes into missiles.
They dug up water pipes and infrastructure in Gaza to use those
water pipes as missiles and and rockets to shoot them into Israel.
They also Now, hold on. I think if Sulphers around, she'd probably
know the counter to this. There's a counter to this where it's
like technically I think the water pipes they they dredged up
were water pipes that were not in use in any way. So there's
like there's some like propaganda that like the UN paid for new
water pipes in like one of the cities and they dug them all up
to go and um to go and build missiles and it was like no no the
water pipes the UN gave like those all exist and are still there.
These ones were like apparently going I I don't know why they
weren't in use anymore. I that's what I've heard but I actually
don't know. So give that like a 5% chance of being true. Also,
you say they use cookies for rocket fuel. Well, I think he already
said that about Yemen as well, like the Houthies. The water pipe
material was taken from an old installation. Yeah, I thought
it was like something that basically was no longer in use. Harbored
most of the um most of the humanitarian aid that came into Gaza
was used by Kamas. Hamas took them over. They um didn't give
out a lot to a lot of people. Um
uh in fact, if you look at the leaders of Kamas, they're billionaires,
right? Well, I mean that's like that's I mean so is Nancy Pelosi.
Okay. Um interesting. What I mean I understand why Nancy Pelosi
is worth Nancy Pelosi is worth 200 million actually. Okay. Well
I mean Richard Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I I was confused why you were
saying like yeah of course they cut off water and electricity
to their enemies. I'm like well yeah I mean I thought you were
arguing that they didn't do that but it looks like what you're
saying is they for a while they gave it to them for a while and
then it got worse and then they stopped. Right. Yeah. But why
would if they're doing Oh yeah yeah yeah yeah wait so why what
is the logic okay so they they provided for a while then it got
worse so they stopped what was worse October 7th that's come
since then for the Israelis I don't know s but um yeah I literally
don't know what the argument is I don't know what could have
even possibly have happened like where it got worse so they stopped
like I mean you can make the argument they were strategic uh
like uh turning off the utilities or whatever but depends on
what he means by got worse. Got worse for the Israelis. I don't
know how many deaths have they even incurred. I I literally don't
know. I do know they have lost people in obviously. I'm sure.
Yeah, obviously they've lost people in combat, but like compared
to like uh I don't know. Like have they lost a thousand? I don't
know. Hold on. IDF
casualties. Uh not a thousand in one incident, that's for sure.
authorities named 856 soldiers on Gaza Gaza ground offensive
and at least 414 during a ground offensive in the Hamas run territory
amid operations on the border. So 856 since October 7th. Yeah.
So the total isn't even at the the death count for October 7th.
So like the idea it got worse at any point is just like I don't
know man. Whatever. Why they gave it to them for a while and
then it got worse and then they stopped. Right. Yeah. But why
would if they're doing No. No. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm saying like it's like what like obviously things have gotten
worse. I mean March is very recently things have gotten worse
obviously. So I am not I'm not saying I'm not saying that this
is justified of Israel to do. I'm saying that this proves it's
not a genocide that they have provided them with those resources.
You're g you're there they're giving food and electricity supposedly
to a people that genocide. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, that's I mean
that that I mean I see what you're saying. Yeah. Dude, this is
like the clumsiest conflation of Palestinians and Hamas. It's
like it's like not even he's not hiding anything. He should be
hiding his power level way more than this when he's having this
conversation. He clearly thinks any tactics against the Palestinians
are justified because of what Hamas did.
Yeah. And they only recently uh yanked it. Okay, that makes sense.
All right. Um sorry, we got very sidetracked, but I think this
is educational. like I'm learning about this conflict and like
obviously, you know,
um I I prefer to to hear it from somebody who I know rather than
like, you know, a mainstream news outlet or whatever. Uh my my
news is is Okay, if it's not Asmin Gold, I don't trust it. Okay,
true.
He said he was joking. Hey, he say he was joking. He told me
he was joking. But um anyway, so um continue with with with Do
you believe him? I'm I'm giving him charity. Yeah. Okay. So,
Hassan is is lying about which of the following things that you've
just informed me about, right? Um, well, the genocide part, uh,
I guess, but that that one's contested. Subjective, right? Nux
is an American Canadian dual citizen who is Jewish and lives
in Israel. Technically don't even know for sure that he's Jewish,
but I assume if he's living in Israel that he that's how he would
get there. But, stop. No way. No, that's true. That is 100% true.
That is what he says as far as he reports it, right? I mean,
I guess it's a really I think it's it's more about how you define
genocide and right and like and like how you relate that to what's
happening, right? Noox lives in Israel. I believe he went and
saw Destiny when Destiny went to Israel. Yes, I believe he lives
in Israel. Yeah. No, that was uh that was which given his lollycon
browsing past, you know, a lot of patterns adding up here for
this conversation so far. Not good. That that one's contested.
So, I I don't I don't fault him for that one. Absolutely not.
Um I I there are arguments to be made on all sides even though
I personally one side is more accurate than the other side. Sure.
I think it's I also do think it's like the way in which he uses
it to like deflect all criticism is soing babyish. True. It's
how can you criticize me when there's a genocide? Yeah. Literally
literally it's like h how am I the problem when Israel's the
problem? It's like bro it's like okay bro. Yeah. Espe like and
again if you're I don't necessarily want to defend him there
but I do believe he mostly uses that criticism for people who
claim that they think like Israel is a problem. Yeah. I don't
know if you had like a gigazionist who was criticizing him if
he'd go why are you criticizing me during a genocide? I don't
think that's a defense he would use but I don't know it possibly
but from what I understand that's mostly like you say you love
like uh you say you like support Palestine, free Palestine. Okay,
why are you attacking me? Which again still isn't a good point,
but hey, if you really wanted to look at the problem, this war
started because kamas are terrorists, right? Well, okay. Yeah,
October 7th. Sure. That's what was the escalation. I mean, people
were saying this has been happening for a while, though, to be
honest. Cosmo, he is not American. He's not living in America.
He's in he's not in Israel. Okay. Right. So, do you want do you
want American but he's in Israel? Let's do it because I keep
hearing about October 7th, right? or or don't don't don't go
just explain to me why October 7th happened, right? Obviously,
you know, you can't explain why a group of people would, you
know, a group of people like that's irrational. That's primal.
It's like I don't know if we could call it irrational. Maybe
you could call it irrational because of the long-term issues,
right? The long-term like occup like obviously military operation
issues, but it's like if I if I had to guess what they would
do if they ever broke out of there, murder and are like the top
two on the list, right? Like it's totally predictable. But maybe
you could argue it's not rational. It's like 100%. However, obviously
as a group there was something that caused that, I would assume.
Right. So So what was the thing that caused that? You know what
what were the Israelis wearing, Nux? Tell me what they were wearing.
Tell me why they deserved it. Was a Queenman tweet. Hold on.
Pull this up. Pull this up. I have to see what it is. What is
this? What's Mudahar's problem? ESL disability. I didn't watch
any of your Mudahar Max stuff, so I got no idea what this is
about. Wow. It's a tweet. It's a Queenman tweet. Oh my god. Everyone
go vote. Yeah. Wow. Crazy. I don't know how to vote on that.
So, you're gonna have to go without me, my friends. You're gonna
have to go without me. I don't I don't know what the context
is there. Son literally had an answer for this when he said it
was retribution. Um. Oh, sure. Yeah. I think it's just I think
it's literally one of those things where it's like you haven't
you haven't done anything to these people and now that you're
like out here and you have a chance to rampage, you're going
to rampage. take out all the all the um inherited rage of your
people if or if you I mean if just make it quick if you can I
don't know you can't make you can't make the history of Israel
Palestine quick um okay sure I don't I mean if you if you don't
want to get into it we don't have to to be honest all right so
um so there were um you ever you ever read the Bible I actually
have not I know a lot of Bible passages but I've not read the
Bible fully all right so there was this guy by the name of King
I've read parts of it I know the king of Israel. All right. So,
uh, in Jerusalem right now, there still is the city of David,
um, from like 3,000 years ago. It's pretty old. Um, so at some
point eventually, the Romans drove the Jews out of Israel. A
lot of them, there were still Jews in Israel, but they drove
the Jews out of Israel. Okay, everyone's zoning out. Just like
what caused October 7th? That that's the point I'm trying to
make.
Uh, do any of you guys watch Hold on. Any of you guys watch the
unbiased history of Rome? Anybody? Any enjoyers? Should we watch
Should we watch the clip? We watch the clip. Uh oh. Uh oh. I
This might get me This would be a problem if we watch it. Does
anyone know what I'm talking about? He just talked about when
Romans uh sacked Jerusalem. Okay. I don't know if I should play
this. This guy is not anti-Semitic though. Okay. To absolute
isolation, suffering way. So Hrien Hrien was emperor. Okay. Hrien
was emperor. Sadness, grief, and lots lots of anger. Meanwhile,
the Jews were added again, about to throw yet another revolt.
I believe this is the second or third revolt they'd had in like
70 years in Jerusalem. Led by the proclaimed Messiah Barba, he
promised to retake Judea by any means necessary. He gathered
his fanatical Jews, slaughtered the local Roman garrisons, and
retook Jerusalem for themselves. When the local legions tried
to restore peace, they were pushed back by half a million rebel
Jews. Bakoka purged Judea of all non-Jews, Romans and Christians
alike, along with their wives and children. When news of the
massacre reached the emperor, Hrien
mad. He sailed for Judea, followed by 12 legions, and started
every single Jew he found. No mercy was showed, no quarter given.
Adrian would settle with nothing less than the complete destruction
of
Hey, come on. This is what an actual genocide is. Are you Are
you okay? Are you okay playing this stuff? Are you good? This
is not as anti-Semitic person. And he's made my favorite video
of all time, which is his uh history of Israel, which is awesome.
It's an even better video. His uh Israel unbiased history.
This is an even better video. It's so awesome. By the way, this
is like actually how you explain Israel's history in 10 minutes
without it up. Well, okay. It's a little crazy. This guy's ill.
No, this guy is awesome. This guy, this video is awesome. Except
the whole shtick is that you tell the history in a way that's
like So, you know how people like started like trying to tear
down their own country's heroes and stuff because of like colonial
leg legacies and this is like the opposite where it's like actually
we won and that's why we're awesome and we're going to just talk
about how awesome we are. So, this video spends like a lot of
time glorifying Chiron and some other people. It's a fantastic
video. Anyway, we probably don't have time for it right now.
I'll watch it eventually. Sorry, Nux was just Nux was giving
us the history, so I figured I'd give the history, too. There's
no way. There's just no way. There's actually no way. There's
There's no way I can uh I could just say what caused it in a
second. There's Okay. Okay. But just real quick, there wasn't
like a thing like IDF was like or or Israel was did some and
then they did this. You're think it's all this history? No, it's
because Israel became a country. They didn't want Israel to become
a country. It's ever since Israel became a country that they
were. was like in like 1960 something. So in 1948 the British
mandate made Israel a country cuz before that it was under the
British mandate. So the British decided to make Israel a country
at that po at that point there were oh I forgot he's like so
about this. Oh my god. Listen to the language. It's ever since
Israel became a country that they were like in like 1960 something.
Yeah. This is all in 1948 the British mandate made Israel a country
cuz the British mandate made Israel a country. He means that
the there was a proposed UN partition plan and then Israel declared
themselves a country. Uh Israel was formerly a part of the British
mandate for Palestine. There was no mandate from the British
that Israel is now a country. That is not a thing that exists.
This is uh indescribably bad. Before that it was under the British
mandate. So the British decided to make Israel a country. At
that at that point there were still majority Arabs in Israel.
Um and then after 1948 a lot more majority Arabs in Israel. I
believe that's not correct. I believe it was a 55% Jewish population
in the borders that they declared. And then after 1948 a lot
more Jews entered Israel. Is it to start saying that like Israeli
independence was a or the Israeli partition was a mistake or
something like that? What what's like the most British colonial
way to start to start saying this? Uh uh the Balpour declaration
was a mistake maybe. Uh I feel like that's it's like you know
it's too far back. Too far. Yeah. Okay. I don't even know cuz
like I think both sides just basically thought that the British
was taking the other side, right? Isn't that the whole idea?
Like the Arabs were like, "Oh, the British are totally on your
side." The Jews were like, "The British keeping us over." I don't
know. I think I don't think the British like outright supported
the Jews. I don't think that's like really I don't know. I I
don't think that's really what the Brits kind of I think the
Brits were basically like suck each other and both sides were
like no you Jews actually become a much stronger minority in
the country. So at that point there was a uh the Arabs in the
area attacked and um the Jews won. So they actually ended up
getting a country at that point. Uh and so in 1967 there was
another war where um surrounding countries uh attacked and Israel
won another war uh which pushed their Oh, I wasn't listening
to that. I'm sure he's getting things wrong. In 1967, you should
write it back. This is this is a crazy like if you take this
recounting history, it's so funny. The Jews won. So they actually
ended up getting a country at that point. Uh and so in 1967 there
was another war where um surrounding countries uh attacked and
Israel won another again doesn't understand that 67 was nothing
like 48. Um thinks that there was outright I mean there was there
was Arab aggression in a sense that like the Arabs were threatening.
Obviously, there's saber rattling on both sides, but like the
the the preemptive strike was from Israel that started the war.
The war uh which pushed their borders out a little bit longer,
a little bit bigger, and that is current Israel as we have. No,
it's not. Um they got Goolan and Sinai, they gave Sinai back
today from 1960s. Okay. Yeah. So, their borders haven't changed
since then.
The borders have been changed since then. And as it stands, that's
that's a funny question that like I don't think a Cheeto knows
how funny that question is. A lot of they have uh a ton of the
people that lived in that region before that time um in the Palestine
region were displaced. Uh like 600,000 people or something were
displaced from their homes over the course of We just saw that
in somewhere around 67 I guess is what Yeah, at some point here
there was like a knockba. I don't know. seems kind of made up,
but uh about 600,000 people. Also, I don't know what the Nagba
has to do with the borders either. But so anyway, since then
they are all saying, you know, Israel from the river to the sea,
Palestine will be free. The the river is the Jordan River. The
sea is the Red Sea. Um no, it's not. No, no, it's not. It's not
the Red Sea. Uh it's the Mediterranean. Hold on. I'm going to
pull up the maps here. Oh god. God, this guy is so and he talks
about this [__] like he knows anything.
Got to be real, dude. Okay, so here's the thing. Maybe, you know,
he might not be totally Sorry, he is totally incorrect, but he
might not be totally if you count I think it's the Gulf of the
Gulf of Aaba. If you count the Gulf of A where's my map here?
Over here it is. So, if you count this as the Red Sea and maybe
that is correct. Maybe you say the Gulf of Aaba is a part of
the Red Sea or something, right? Like basically the Red Sea does
not technically border Israel. Okay. I swear to God this guy
went to like Hebrew school as a kid and learned that Moses parted
the Red Sea and he was like, "Yeah, guys, we Israel's on the
Red Sea. Israel's totally totally Yeah. From the river to the
sea. They want to go from uh from like here. Okay. They want
to go from like here to like here. From the river to the sea,
guys. Not not this way across all of the populated areas. You
know, this whole this whole thing that basically takes out all
the populated areas here and go down here to the to the Red Sea.
Uhhuh. Wow. Neat. Okay. This guy is a goof. They want to wipe
out all the Jews in Israel. Um and they want to take back the
land. So essentially October 7th is just um it was a gigantic
terrorist attack that was done by people that wanted to call
the Jews in Israel and take the land back. Uhhuh. Do do you think
that like when they say from the river to the sea that they could
be talking about the borders that have moved? Nope. No. Okay.
They the the full phrase is from the river to the sea, Palestine
will be free. And um you know, any Jew hiding behind any tree.
It's the thing I told you before. Any Jew hiding.
Do they have like madeup anti-semitic lyrics for the rest of
that or Oh my god. Amazing. Oh, did I just click this? Hold on.
Reds. Get get Kanye onto this.
nope. No. Okay. The the full phrase is from before. Any Jew behind
behind any tree, the tree will say there's a Jew behind me. Come
the Jew. Gotcha. So, he just added the hadith to the chant. I
guess that's the hadith. But I don't know why he said that's
the full phrase. Like he just made that up that like from the
river to the sea also has the hadith attached in some way. Gotcha.
Gotcha. Okay, gotcha. Okay. Um, Jesus, this is like the Vladimir
Putin, Tucker Carlson where he just gives like the uh in 1451.
Um, okay. So much I do love the there's some level of introspection
there, okay? Some level of self-awareness where he does just
say it. He's like, you know what? No, no, no. He's saying he's
like Tucker Carlson, right? And he's just like accepting things
and he doesn't know. So, he's just like nodding and laughing.
I think that's what he's saying there, right? Yeah. Yeah, basically
he doesn't know enough to disagree. Yeah. Um Okay. Yeah. You're
like you're Vladimir Putin. How does it feel? It's great. Oh,
yeah. Okay. Okay. So, so then so then what else has Hassan lied
about in this conflict? Cuz you've got to have more ammo. Yeah.
Well, dude, so much. And I I don't think I'll have time for Well,
so first of all, um remember Hassan says that Gaza before October
7th, that's a phrase. You cut out you cut out. You cut out. What
did you say? Gaza before says that Gaza before October 7th was
a concentration camp. So they had to That's like a big argument.
Dude, you cut out again. What the You said Gaza was a concentration
camp. What? What did you say? You cut says Assan says that the
reason why the October 7th attack was justified is because before
October 7th, Gaza was a giant concentration camp. Okay. For Jews,
for Palestinians. Okay. Gotcha. Palestinians. So this was Gaza
before October 7th. Like this does not look like a concentration
camp, right? It looks pretty chill actually. He widely wildly
misrepresents the conditions there to justify the terrorist attack
that took place. Mhm. That's another thing that he does all the
time. Wow. Um
does this look like any kind of concentration camp you've ever
seen, guys? No. Another one that I personally think is uh When
did he Wait, sorry, real quick. When does When did he say that?
Because that's crazy. How could you? Because if that video is
right there and and it's obvious that Gaza is not a concentration
camp, then how does he get away with lying like that? Uh I don't
know. He does. He says it all the time. He literally says it
all the time. Okay. And people believe him. Why do they believe
him? Because it's cuz he's 6'6 and hot. Okay. People just believe
him. He can say anything. The project. It's the process. I I
think you don't understand something. People aren't watching
Hassan. People aren't watching Hassan to um to broaden their
political perspectives. People are watching Hassan to essentially
propagate the same propaganda that they want. Okay. Gotcha. Anyway,
um here's here's I'll show you this one. I have to show you this
one and then I'm gonna wrap I'm gonna go Yeah. Yeah. Sounds good.
Sounds good. Sorry to keep you here for so long, but it's actually
interesting to me. I'm trying to learn. I mean, I honestly am.
Yeah. So, this this is my uh this is my favorite one. Check this
out. So, this is titled uh another journalist killed by Israel.
As you know, journalists is a war crime. Yeah. So, pull the chat
up. That's where I come in. This one is rough. Israel killed
two journalists yesterday. One of them is someone who I frequently
talk to to get updates. He was a contributor to Al Jazer. I've
talked about him before. His name is Hassam Shabbat. He was 23
years old. Israel had uh put him on a leaflet claiming that he
was I wish I could be in chat with my actual name in some way
so people would recognize me, but I have to use different names.
Terrorist alongside other journalists a couple months prior,
which was a death sentence. and I reached out to him at the time
when I So anyway, this is an entire 10-minute eulogy of saying
that the poor Hassam Shabbat journalist was killed. It's a war
crime in Israel, blah blah blah. Right. Well, that sounds sad.
What happened? Incredibly sad. It really is incredibly sad. A
war crime, right? He got this from Al Jazer, um a Qatar um propaganda
outlet. Uh but anyway, so this is Ham Shabbat, the guy in the
press suit right here. But if you look if you look at the list
of um fighters, this is Shabbat, a sniper. It's a very clean
list here. Kamas and uh he's on a list. Yeah, but Brazilian lab
Brazilian lab. Where do you think that list is from? I'll give
you two guesses. This was defined by Hamas. Kamas claims that
he is a sniper for Kamas. That's not true, by the way. That's
not true. Oh,
wait. He did not say Wait, Noox did not just say he got this
from Alazero, did he? Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
This is from a very specific place. I looked this tweet up. My
god. Yeah. So, that was a that was a big one when I saw that.
Um, no way. So, he's saying that his buddy who was a journalist
was a terrorist sniper.
Yeah. So, he Oh my, bro. What? This one was wild. I love this
one. Why did we ever go any of Why did we start to go, bro? Why
did we spend so much time on the history when you had this in
the back pocket the whole time? Hassan's buddy was a sniper.
It happens. We It happens. This It's so good. What everyone wanted.
I'm sitting here like scratching my head thinking about the mystery
and you have a literal brochure with this. Bro, come on. That's
insane.
This this seems like something a paramilitary like gorilla organ
organization would have and just publish somewhere, right? A
full list of all of their fighters names. Definitely. You should
watch the how does a sound per channel. Uh but anyhow, in case
you wanted more proof that
was a bad guy. All right, so this is that Hassam Shabbat guy.
If you look at this, you will notice something. Well, hold on.
Hold on. I mean I mean I mean I mean we'll pause real quick.
I mean, look, whether or not he had to do this to like, you know,
fight in the war, forget that. I'm more like Yeah, exactly. Sulfur,
you know. Yes. The only source for him being a Hamas sniper is
the IDF. The IDF was just like, "Yeah, he's a sniper actually."
Yeah, he's in. Yeah. No, no. They said, "This guy's a sniper.
This guy, this guy's a terrorist." And he said, "No, I'm not.
You're using it as a pretext to kill me." And then they killed
him and then they murdered him. Yes. Asan said, "This guy's a
bitch." A journalist,
a journalist friend. Don't worry, critical rat. We get to this
getting disproven literally in this video. We don't even need
an accompanying video for this. If Israel is committing war crimes,
that's that's what I'm saying. That's that's the point, guys,
is like Hassan said that the sniper is a journalist. Like like
no, like that's what I like you could have an argument about
the ethics of him being a sniper in a war period. Okay, forget
that. The best part about this is like I was like, couldn't you
find if you're going to say that he's like a Hamas terrorist,
couldn't you find like an example of him like wearing some fatigues
with like a gun or something?
Literally all the like 95% of the pictures he's in. Yes, it's
a press jacket. Like the whole time like, "Hey, I'm pressed.
Do not kill me. I am not a terrorist. I am press do not kill
me." This Hassan guy is a lie. My guy. My boy. It gets worse.
It does get worse. All right, let's get into it. So this is that
guy, right? The the guy in the press suit. This is Assam Shabbat.
Yeah. Notice the date. Oh my god.
So he posted
entering on October 7th. So this guy this guy uh now I will say
this guy appears to support Hamas and Hamas like striking Israel.
Okay. Yes. But yeah, this is my whole thing when I was watching
this. I'm like, "Dude, this is pictures of it." Like, unfortunately,
even if he didn't, he would still go and take photos of this,
right? Okay. And he's a journalist. Yeah. No, exactly. Like,
he would go as his job and take pictures. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But
I I would say it seems like what? Our youth are fire is like
his caption for the photo. Probably in kind of support of
They're allowed to support Hamas if they want to. Okay. I I believe
in freedom of speech. You don't get to blow up journalists cuz
they spot mass. Uh, okay. I don't like this. Well, they would
say that argument. However likely the Hold on. If the IDF wanted
to say this, they would need to produce any actual evidence of
this guy doing something. That's all they'd have to do. Pumpern
nickel. Produce any evidence. Don't produce one roster that is
just an Excel spreadsheet that says his name is in there. It
says he's a sniper. Show me a picture. Show me him associating
with Hamas people. Show me anything. Anything. He's wearing a
picture. He is wearing the scarf in a picture. The terrorists
that started the war. He is. He dude, this guy needs to get Bro,
I don't want So this guy's dead. Israel killed him because he's
a terrorist. And Hassan gives him an entire eulogy as his friend,
the press guy who um I can't believe my good friend, the press
guy, was killed by Israel.
Chat, one in chat if you knew this, two in chat if you're just
finding this out. This is insane. Thank you for the $10. Oh my
god, the Hassan is 100% ser will blow your mind, chat. This is
crazy. This is crazy. Oh my god. We got a lot of threes. Everybody
knows the three man. This is your reaction to this. It turns
out that the Hamas fighters were also spamming three on that
day. Well, bro, they're 50 minutes each. I lowkey have [__]
to do. But I mean, okay, I felt bad for that. That that made
me feel bad, actually. That's a soul injuring joke. But I mean,
like, but you see now why they're long. Well, yeah. I mean, holy
[__] People knew this. Some people It looks like
50/50. So, a lot of people didn't know this. Well, anyone who
says one watched my videos cuz no one else covered it. That's
insane. Bro did his research. Okay. Uh, continue. No one else
commented. It must be because no
intelligent and picked this one out when no one else did. He's
a terrorist. This gets very funny. Well, especially if he was
part of the October 7th attacks, then he is like literally he
is part of the Knox, by the way, is not even good at He should
be reading the quotes from these pictures. Like the quote here
is all of Bit Hanan is at the garage receiving kidnapped soldiers
and then he's got like the like Yeah, you should point out that
he clearly supports this operation happening. Okay, even if he
isn't a terrorist, he supports this operation happening. October
7th attacks and he is like literally not even good. Yeah, he
is part of Israel. I'm not making enough streaming. You could
supplement my income, I would go way harder for you. Okay, any
MSAD agents are watching this. Genocide. Dan Saltman. Dan Saltman.
I believe Dan Saltman may be watching right now. I know you've
got connections, Dan. If I get a 100 subs right now, I'll flip
totally. Okay. Hassan will actually be bad again. I promise that
doesn't seem like it's October 7th. That's crazy, bro. I cried
apparently. Or at least he uh he videoed them going in. Uhhuh.
But anyway, what else was there? Yeah. Well, that that's what
I got for this one. Okay. Well, what else did you say? Wait,
wait, but you played 9 seconds of it. We'll play more of it though
because we got the whole video about him before. His name is
Hassam Shabbat. He was 23 years old. Israel had put him on a
leaflet claiming that he Sorry, someone in chat said Israel accused
him of being Hamas with no verifiable proof. Because he took
photos doesn't mean he's a terrorist. What do you think about
that? Yes, I don't know. He took photos of the October 7th attack.
He took photos of people entering the into the country before
they entered the country. Right. Could Could you go back to that
thing that showed that he's a sniper? If someone said
bactic that's that's awesome. Who is this? Who is this? Like
who who's file? This is a list of operatives in company one of
the bait hanoon battalion. And so so what file like who who made
this basically? So I assume Israel put this together. Um, but
where does this information come from? Israel got these um these
uh charts I'm pretty sure from what they actually found from
Kamas cuz there were a lot of right cuz he died cuz he died and
they figured him out, right? No, they this was long before he
died. Wait, what? Was they put a they mentioned before he died
like he Hassan actually says that was a terrorist alongside five
other journalists. Right. So the IDF claims uncovered documents
prove six Alazer journalists are terrorists. Surely surely these
uncovered documents were shared and aren't just like the the
Excel spreadsheets that were shared, right? Surely. Uh and that
includes the Hassam Shabbat guy. Okay. Interesting. What? So
this is after he was murdered, right? He was murdered in March
and then they're like months later they're like, "Look, we found
proof. Proof months prior." which sorry someone testing what
Hassan is saying is true and it's what does Wikipedia says too.
What does Wikipedia say? Sorry I'm just I'm just trying to you
know like look at everything but continue. I want I want to hear
how he's well cuz death sentence and I reached out to him at
the time when I saw that and you know he did not seem discouraged.
He was steadfast and till the very last breath he was trying
to put the word out about what was happening to his people, what
was happening to the Palestinians. Dylan Saba had a really good
statement on this and I want to read it. He said, "Ham was 23
years old. At age seven, he saw Israel's ground invasion of Gaza
that
1,400 Palestinians. At age 10, a major air assault. At age 11,
another ground invasion that killed 2,200. At age 19, another
Man, I wonder why if you saw multiple you had thousands of people
around you dying when you were in your formative years. I wonder
why he might know not like these Israeliation.
Yeah. Yeah. Crazy massive bombing. I do think going with Hamas
on October 7th raid itself. He didn't go with them on the raid
as far as I know. As far as I know, he photographed them leaving
Gaza. Probably knowing that if you left Gaza, if you were photographed
anywhere outside of that fence, you were found anywhere outside
of that fence. You were going to be killed. He probably was like,
"Yeah, I'll videotape them leaving." I haven't seen any photos
of him being out and about taking like video while people are
getting murdered. I'm pretty sure he just took videos of them
breaking through the fence and leaving, which again, as a journalist,
you'd probably want to do anyway. campaign. And at age 22, the
start of this holocaust. He faced a genocide his entire life
as the world conspired to forget and erase. Also, how do you
know he didn't tip anybody off about October 7th? Bumpern nickel.
As far as I know, those hang gliders were breaking out like way
before they broke through the fence. His existence and those
of his people. We will never erase the moral stain of this horror.
Israel is deliberately targeting the last couple of journalists
that are basically alive in Gaza at this point. One of his last
messages that he ever posted was actually about his colleague
that Israel had assassinated a couple moments prior, like an
hour prior to his own assassination. These are Yeah, I agree,
Miss Elli. I think the uh the vocal fry I'm about to cry thing
is a little bit much. I I said that when this was happening,
I said, "I can't stand the combination of low res voice and pensive
delivery." And then there were like I think either two or three
women in chat started defending it. So I figured I was completely
wrong on that. Are real human beings. They have dreams.
No, no, you're totally correct cuz you're complaining about the
audio. If you literally shut the video off for them, they'd be
like, "Yeah, I get it." So yeah, I I kind of get where the point
is, but um it's it's a whole eulogy. That that was the point.
Yeah. Um, I guess like a lot of people in chatter are saying
that because like the um the screenshot you showed me is like
from Israel that it's kind of um like mixed. They can't really
verify it. And then someone was saying it's on Wikipedia that
he's not a sniper. I forget the guy who said that, but um I have
to look into it. Yeah, I forget the guy who said that too. What
do you think about that? I'd love to see that. If you show it
to me, I'd love to see it. That would um Yeah. Um I don't know
if you're still in chat, but the guy who said look at the Wikipedia.
Can you show me the Wikipedia? Apparently, he has a military
ID number from 2019 training in Kamas battalions. What's his
name? Oh, Hassam Basel Abdul.
I would love to see though. I would correct it for sure.
Oh, okay. Yeah, I I have the Wikipedia. Um, okay. So, it says,
uh, okay, nothing's showing. Okay. Uh, Hassam Shabbat was a
journalist, too. Uh, okay. who who report on the Gaza war as
a course. He was he was definitely Oh, the IDF did just say,
"Yeah, we air struck this guy directly." Yeah, kind of gigg moment.
Witnesses reported that the attack appeared to be targeted and
the IDF later acknowledged that they had targeted Assam a journalist.
The question is if he was also a terrorist, right? Well, it's
like saying Hitler was a painter, right? You know, okay. Shabbat
was killed by an Israeli air strike after Israel ended the ceasefire
in January 2025. Oh, I thought he died on October 7th. Okay.
By resuming air strikes in Gaza. He was uh he was videoing the
attack on Okay. Another Palestinian journalist.
Uh Muhammad Mansour was also cured by the Israeli military witness.
Okay. Where's the October 7th stuff? Let's check out the death.
The IDF had previously threatened Hassan Hassam on the 23rd of
October 2024 and accused six journalists including Assam of being
members of Hamas.
Hassam denied he denied any involvement and also stated these
were clear death threats that they serve as an excuse to preemptively
justify killing him. Interesting.
On the following day, the IDF confirmed that they had deliberately
targeted Shabbat, stating that during the war, Shabbat carried
out attacks and participated in terrorist activities against
the IDF. So, this is just like a he said, she said, isn't it?
Yeah, exactly. Oh, wait. The IDF provided no evidence to support
the claim that Shabbat had attacked the IDF troops or Israeli
cit. So basically like is there proof that he is a terrorist
or not? Like the proof that you showed me is is like interesting
that they classified him as a sniper, but like is it true though
is kind of what I'm getting at. I guess you don't know. I guess
I don't know. In a war, you never know. Okay. Well, is that so
everybody who's watching was that um you think that's how Nux
was delivering that before? Or it could go either way really.
He wasn't being like, "Oh my god, I got the creme de la creme
proof on as a total lying loser right here. Look, read them and
weep, boys. This guy was a sniper. He wasn't a journalist at
all." You do know that he was taking these images of them actually
entering Israel on October 7th, right? I mean, this was a surprise
terrorist attack. You do know that even if even if maybe they
didn't provide proof that he um he actually attacked specific
people, you do know for a fact that he um he does have a military
ID number from the kamas battalion of 2019. Right. The only proof
that from what I understand according to this Wikipedia article
they don't have is that he directly attacked. So they have proof
apparently that he went to military training. Okay. In the city
that he was from. Does he have an option for that? Or do you
get conscripted to do military training? Does he have the option
to not do military training from Hamas? And then if he doesn't
have the option, then aren't you just agreeing that basically
every single civilian is in Israel is a viable target, right?
So this is basically from 2019 and he was what 24 years old or
something? From shortly after he turned 18, he did military training
with Hamas apparently, right? But then he went and became a journalist.
Unless you have proof of him engaging in these activities, then
I don't understand how you haven't just green lit attacks on
anybody who's off duty IDF because it's mandatory conscription.
Is it like the IDF? I don't know. So, he had knowledge of the
attack beforehand. Valid target. He was a part of the October
7th attack. You can make that argument, I guess, but I don't
know if he had I don't know what fornowledge he had. I don't
know if they didn't just say like, "Hey, come take pictures of
this. We're about to break out when they collaborate." So, what
you just sight Oh, there there is that angle, too. Yeah.
and if you don't tell them you're killed by Israel. Okay, cool.
You can just give all of them in. Sweet based. No, you don't
have to join. Well, I didn't think there was mandatory like um
Yeah, I I wouldn't think it was like on the books or maybe they
would talk about it. No, you don't have to join Hamas, but there's
a lot of social incentive to go, especially depending on how
old he was when he went that you pull your weight and the Hamas
and other Gorg pay. Well, I'm just saying like there could be
something like, okay, you're not a part of like active duty,
but they could train people, right? I don't know that this military
training from Hamas and I don't know if this is military training
even. I don't know if if it's even real. Okay. But I'm saying
that like there's there's no reason to believe that just because
he had been a part of Hamas in 2019 that he hadn't like changed
something up and done this or that this like means he was a sniper
or active because they're claiming he was active. And if he was
active then I just assume they'd have any evidence at all. Yeah.
Who'd he show you? He was there at the pos. Okay. So Travis Lamb
listen right. Okay. He's a journalist. They know he's a journalist.
Somebody says, "Hey, we're going to break out. I'm take pictures.
It's going to be our like liberation moment." Does he not go
as a journalist? He goes, "No, you know what? I'm a journal.
I I as a journalist, I do not want to take pictures of this like
historic event. I actually want to stay here. Could have been
training to be part of civil defense or the police. Both run
both moss run in Gaza, but I don't know when it was. Oh, yeah.
Yeah. I you have to see these these documents in more detail.
I I don't understand why he would like not go and take pictures
of them leaving. And I I assumed that if he left that there would
be pictures of him having left, but maybe troops or civilians
that they didn't. A journalist on planes for 9/11. Uh that's
not like a comparable thing. That would be weird. Well, I feel
like that's the most important part. Well, if you're part of
a terrorist organization and they get you. Um I think that that's
valid personally. Well, I I don't think so. Like even if I'm
part of like a terrorist group, like whether or not I actually
do terrorism matters. You know, you know what would be a bigger
story? Getting photos of the IDF stopping Hamas. Do you think
this likes the IDF. The IDF's probably killed several people
in his life. He doesn't like the IDF. He hates Israel. He has
no moral duty whatsoever to call Israel and say, "Hey, actually,
uh, they're coming. Hamas is coming. What are you talking about?"
That's crazy that you could like not understand what these people
are like, the experiences they have at all. That you'd be like,
"Dude, it's his moral duty to like inform Israel that there's
a terrorist attack coming." That's crazy. It's crazy that you
could think that, you know. Well, maybe he didn't didn't do terrorism
yet. You're arguing that only terrorists that have already killed
people should be targeted. That just means he is from a terrorist
state. Yes. He's literally from a state that is managed by a
terrorist organization. Yes. And to them, the IDF is a terrorist
state, too. Sorry. The Israel is a terrorist state, too. Israel
constantly bombs them. I think so. Many
tens of thousands of civilians have died in the past like two
years. a war. Well, I think that's what makes you a terrorist
is doing the terrorism.
I don't know if necessarily being is trying to do the terrorism.
Well, we don't know if he was trying to, do we? I guess I guess
what I'm trying to say videoing them going in on October 7th.
Well, I I guess what I'm trying to say is like um what I'm trying
to understand is like Well, Pumpern Nickel, I don't know that
he would break OBSC for the Hamas raid, right? I don't know if
he would break OBSC for that Hamas raid. Dude, he's planning
to be in Gaza. Do you know what they do to
You have any idea? It's [__] wild. I guess like how
do we know that Hassan is like lying versus like the Israel is
lying? Cuz like necess isn't this kind of a he said she said.
I suppose it is a he said she said but I also suppose that Hassan
giving the of um my good friend the terrorist was killed. It's
a war crime without giving context that the guy is probably a
terrorist is kind based on a one form from the idea kind of wild.
Unless she does say that yeah that Israel accused him and there
was basically a death sentence that when Israel accused him of
being a terrorist and then Israel drone struck this guy. It wasn't
even like they just got him randomly. They're like, "No, no,
no. We know that you did this. We know you're a terrorist." I
feel like Israel was just like, "I think you uh you didn't warn
us. We're just going to send a message here. You were taking
photos when they left. Uh good luck. You're dead." But I mean,
why is he probably a terrorist? Like he I just think Listen,
Wikipedia tends to be fairly good. Okay. Uh, where is his Wikipedia
page? Did I not open up? It's on my other tab, isn't it? Assam
Shabbat. I just assumed they would actually put something here
to say he was like a terrorist, right? All they say is Israel
had accused him of this. So, Wikipedia's on smack apparently.
Anyway, uh, we're getting close to I I don't understand this
October 7th attack is one of the worst terrorists attack. Nope.
Nope. Yeah. Yeah. 100%. No, I'm not justifi I think this is terrible.
I'm just trying to understand that this specific person was part
of it, right? Because you show me the thing that was registered
as a sniper. But I'm losing you. I need to make sure you still
disavow October 7th, right? It's one of the worst terrorist attacks
ever, right? Oh my god. And I will say the fact that he was profiled
before as a sniper is kind of like, well, how did they catch
him before as a sniper, right? I mean, cuz if he'd already been
if he No, I'm saying I'm saying Exactly. I'm saying I'm saying
if he if he was in the database already, that's kind of sus,
right? That's what I'm saying. But I also don't know if what
you're showing me is like proof that he carried out terrorism
on October 7th. Okay. Well, I mean I mean I'm just trying to
under I mean I'm not trying to like argue with you. I'm just
trying to like No, no, please argue with me. I don't mind if
you This guy is a I thought the history of the Jewish people
was like rabbis being legendary debaters. Okay. This guy is an
embarrassment to his people's legacy. Mr. Naktaku, this is sad.
This is a sad state. Argue with I'm just trying to get to the
bottom of it. I mean like is there anything else that shows that
he did like terrorism? Uh I would suggest you watch my video
then because I made this video like 6 months ago. Yeah. Yeah.
I'll I'll definitely go watch it. Okay. Can you link it to me?
Yeah, I'll try to find it. Dope. I mean look I mean like all
I'm saying is like look he he definitely he definitely um lied
about a lot of stuff like I mean 100%. Like you showed me stuff
that he lied about like the circumstantial evidence stuff. Lied
about that you know. Um wait did Naktaku prove that in this video
in this stream? I don't think he did. Which one? I think he just
categorized what Hassan said. I don't think he showed what Hassan
said around the the report. No. Yeah. No, he didn't. Yeah. So,
J's like, "You've already showed me him lying." It's like, "No,
he didn't." There's something earlier you also said and then
he completely lied about this. This one specifically. I'm just
trying to make sure. I don't like I don't know if he li If you're
saying it's a he said, she said, "Well, then I I can't definitively
say that he lied about it, you know?" That's fair. For sure.
Gotcha. All right. Well, I think it's Oh god, it's an hour long.
I'll watch it. I think it's this one. I'll send it to people
that value. Yeah, link it to me. I'll watch it. I'm pretty sure
it's this one. I could be wrong. I titled the videos terribly,
so not not exactly super helpful, but I'm pretty sure it's this
one. Yeah. Um, Hassan is 300 now. Yeah. Okay, cool. Um, yeah,
I'll watch this. Well, I mean, look, I know this was like totally
random. I'm sorry for dragging you here for so long. I'm genuinely
trying to look look like I I mean this when I say like I and
this isn't I'm not like pleading ignorance to like pretend that
I don't know something to like whatever. I literally and I mean
this like most of my life I spend is copying lyrics's entire
persona. I can't say that for sure. I don't know. But Shido's
been around a lot longer than Lyrics, hasn't he? I don't know
either playing video games or live streaming like you know content.
So I actually do I don't watch the news. I don't I mean I watch
Aspen Gold. I watch you. I don't know specifically the ongoing
conflict with Israel and Palestine. And so if I ask a lot of
questions, I'm gonna be asked too many questions. I'm not trying
to bug you. You know, it's not your job. It's not your job to
educate me. It's not your job to The thing is I'm not The problem
is with criticizing Hassan and pointing out lies and stuff is
um very often I think a lot of people would just say, "Oh, I
guess uh I guess Snuck supports the entire attack and every single
instance, every person that was killed." And that is obviously
not true at all. Um
but you know, yeah. Well, I think the terrorists, I guess. I
mean, I think anyone who's making a generalization about your
beliefs is probably just, you know, um doing that. Like, I think
that's bad faith. But, um Okay. So, I'm just I just opened Twitter
and typed in I apparently just grasping at whatever straws he
can. This is Listen, I opened up Twitter and this is the Hassam
Shabbat thing again over here from the IDF. Oh, okay. What is
this? Um Shabbat. On October 23rd, the IDF publicly warned that
Hassam Shabbat wasn't just a journalist. He was a confirmed Hamas
operative. Despite the exposure, this journalist still chose
to move openly in the field. Here he is carrying another eliminated
terrorist friend, right? So, a journalist is not supposed to
be doing this. I'm being like a ball bearer for somebody being
buried. A journalist is not supposed to do this. This is disgusting.
Journalists are supposed to be like supposedly unbiased. What
is he doing here that's biased? So this is actually it's like
the same thing as basically this is this is equivalent to being
in the military operations on October 7th. He might as well been
paragliding to be frank. Don't strike him now.
Get him out on his little Is he dead? Yeah. Okay. I mean whatever.
I feel like if it's was very connected. I mean well it says friend.
I don't think that's literal. I think that's just calling saying
that both of them are terrorists. Uhhuh. Okay. I mean I don't
know. I don't know. I'm not going to say I know that. Yeah, I
don't know either. I mean, he might he might be a terrorist.
I I literally don't know. Like I from what you showed me, it's
interesting from what he's saying or Hassan is saying. He's I
mean, it seems like nobody knows, right? And so I'm just sitting
here. I don't know. I suppose like he he might be a terrorist,
I suppose. I mean, like
maybe I mean I don't know if I I mean the thing that you said
that I I don't know. I don't know. This is a lot to take in.
This Yeah, this guy. What is this? A forgotten picture of the
Shabbat. Oh, what is this? A man with absolutely no ties to Hamas
at all. Nobody ever said no ties to Hamas at all. They said he
was not engaged in military operations on October 7th. That's
very different. That's very different. An anti-Trump. This is
checkmate, right? Uh that he's wearing a Hamas scarf or whatever.
No, not when he lives in Gaza. Can you full screen that? I mean
wearing the uh scarf. What? Yeah. I don't know. I don't know
the translation, but it is the it's the kamas scarf. Uhhuh. Again,
it's not evidence he was a terrorist that he's a guy that's wearing
terrorist gear. But like at that point, again, the government
of Gaza, how could you ever prove anything unless they're actually
already killed somebody? Okay. Yeah. But anyh who, I do have
to run. Yeah. No, no problem. I know. I Bro, I mean, you stayed
way longer than you had to. I mean, I really app Thank you. I
mean, I'll link your channel um in the chat obviously, bro. Thank
you so much for joining me. Like I really appreciate this. This
is like really forward. I think a lot of people will learn. I
think a lot of people um
that's just true. Okay. A lot of us did learn. We've learned
many things. Like appreciated you coming on and I I dude I seriously
thank you for for taking the time like actually. And we can do
this again. Like what we'll do next time I'll actually structure
it so we don't we're not going like all over the place. It'll
actually be it'll be it'll be better. It'll be better. Sounds
good. Sorry. Uh, sorry I'm dipping, but no dude, you're good
forever and before that I will only be joining you for 10 seconds.
Of course, of course. Of course, bro. Have a great day or night.
I don't know what time for you, but appreciate it, bro. Cheers.
Absolutely obliterated. All right. Wow, what a video. Noox is
very, very bad at Hasbro. If Israel is paying him, they are paying
too much. Okay, not a bargain. I kind of want to check his latest
stream, see if he uh mentioned this at all. Oh yeah. Um, you
want to watch it now? I'm just having a look now. I'm I'm just
in the background. Oh, it's fine. No, I'll pull it up on stream
right now. Latest stream. I doubt he's Oh, he's just he's been
watching um he's been watching Dragon Ball Z abridged. Oh, hold
on. He's watching Clip. Dan Saltman clip. Quick. More Hassan.
More Hassan. More Hassan. More Hassan. More Han. Oh. Oh, Ethan
Klein. Ethan Klein. Ethan Klein. Denims. Denims. Wow. He's really
got all the content here. Damn. Damn. Uh, maybe he mentions it.
I don't know. But I I think that's it for us, guys. I'm ready
to go to bed. Why did I just go to my dashboard? No, don't go
to my dashboard. Don't do that. Okay, guys. Back tomorrow. Nobody's
online, so no hosting. Destiny. Uh, Destiny stuff's tomorrow.
Could you imagine if I did the Destiny stuff without Kelly Gene
here? Apparently, Destiny said I'm um secretly collaborating
and telling witnesses to lie for Pixie's case. I claim to have
some proof of this. I would love to see him post it. He also
talked about potentially suing me and I literally went into his
chat and I was like, "Please do. Please, please sue me for the
love of God. Please sue me. Please, I would love for you to sue
me." It was funny. He He's He's like getting increasingly unhinged
with his lies. It's um I'm sure it's because everything is fine
and he's going to win his case. And I realistically I would expect
him to win his case or I would have. He's kind of getting so
unhinged. It's getting um I'm begging you said to kill me. What?
What are you talking about? Oh, this guy doesn't like Kelly Jean.
Um, unlucky for you, buddy. But there's no case and it get thrown
out. He's like